This podcast will be a mess.
Just prepare yourself.
If you're an MMA journalist,
put you're a gate.
You're weightlifting chalk on your
hands.
Get ready bitches.
I'm full of opinions.
Everybody had those fucking keyboards.
This is essentially sort of a preview of
this weekend's fights are really just a
chance to get together and fuck around.
I was telling him was a breakdown.
He was told to breakdown.
I've studied all night for a break.
I have my notes.
I was told this is a breakdown.
What are your thoughts,
sir?
I'm glad you asked.
I'm going to go with a.
asked me,
asked me.
Well,
I'm going to go with Nate Diaz now asked
me,
wow,
well,
the way I look at it,
and correct me if I'm wrong,
Connor's boxed.
The daylights had everybody who for the
most part either has his reach or
smallest.
When he does,
he hangs on the edge of the pocket.
He hangs in the age of the pocket and
he's a counter puncher.
Weights to you,
commit slips and hits.
He's dealing with something very
different with nate,
which is that nate is longer and taller
and nate doesn't have to do that and I
wonder what he's going to have to do is
either one of two things is going to
have to weave and get inside or because
nate stands so you know,
flat,
I mean sort of squares up with you.
I guess you could back kick in front
kick is his body,
but connor doesn't kick like it's not
what you think.
Well,
watch out for connor.
Connor's a heart kicks,
you know what I mean?
So he actually takes pretty good kid.
Very good kid.
He does.
I haven't seen much of him because he's
smoking everyone,
but native,
very durable guy too.
He spends a lot of time in those gyms
with a lot of those Mexican boxers that
stand in the hole and just bang,
which is encounter.
It's not but I.
But I,
I wonder how common is going to actually
have to change a little bit of his
boxing and I'm curious to see how he
does.
He's only fought one guy that's tall.
That's Max Holloway and he's
coincidentally the one guy that went to
a decision with him and he was also
hurting that he hurt his knee in that
fight during the fight when he was
passing the guard,
he blew out his acl,
so that definitely had a huge,
huge effect,
but I think that you make some good
points.
I think a dos Anjos showed a bit of the
blueprint on how to beat nate and one of
the big things is that nate stance real
heavy on that front leg.
He comes in,
he fires that hard,
right jab and stands real heavy on that
front leg and dos Anjos just lift that
leg up.
He lit his legs up and because of that
boxing centered style,
me nate will throw the occasional kick,
but primarily he fights boxing when he's
fighting his boxing.
Very good.
It is very sharp.
He boxed up gray maynard.
He boxed up Marcus Davis and Michael.
Josh Thompson,
Michael Johnson.
His last fight was one of his best
fight.
Unbelievable.
Josh Thompson head kicked and knocked
him out,
right?
Yeah.
That was a different.
That was Josh Thompson,
man.
I'd do a 10.
It's a series of injuries,
but I still maintain
he's one of the best lightweight in the
world,
especially when it was in strikeforce.
Yeah,
well he's getting older.
That's the.
The issue is he's like 36 years old.
That's all it is.
Yeah.
I mean,
do you think that Matt Connors met
anyone yet who's has got a boxer?
A snake because no good.
Maybe Max,
maybe Max.
Right.
But Max back then was like,
it was two,
two years ago plus Max was not as good
as he is now.
Confident Max is on fire right now.
Max Holloway is on fire.
I'd like to see him and conor fight.
Fight.
Fuck yeah.
See I don't know about that,
but I don't think that conor really
wants that 1:45
weight class anymore.
I mean he looks so big right now.
He has it and I think,
I think at 55 fighting dose Angeles,
that's the fight at UFC 200.
So if he gets past it actually is kind
of interesting.
If he gets past Nadya's,
you know,
because it makes that fight bigger.
The fight at 200,
it really makes it more build up,
you know,
dos Anjos broke his foot in the last
minute of the last round of sparring to
a huge.
He's going to get the high level a
kickboxer and check the kid broke his
foot,
but we use the same as seuss and of
course you know,
I get the text message,
it's like fuck,
this happened exactly last minute,
last round kind of thing.
That's the thing though.
That's the kings.
They go hard,
man.
They're so good.
Do they were what's like a Shin Pad?
So it's over it.
But if your heart and a kickbox is
checking it,
you kick as hard as he does and you kick
a tree.
You got to fucking break your foot.
Let's see.
I think we know what Nate Diaz is gonna
bring to the table.
I think connor knows.
I think everyone in this room knows what
he's going to do.
We don't know what Congress really going
to do.
Really haven't seen all his tools.
Man.
I think Diaz is the perfect match up so
he can showcase all his tools because
Diaz isn't easy.
I don't think he's gonna get murdered in
the first round.
We're going to see a lot of connor and
what he brings to the table for connor's
really good at lowering you with those
kicks and then stepping in with that big
lefthand had left hand is just a monster
punch from heaven.
Oh Man.
He just throws it so perfect and he's
got so much power behind it,
but I'll tell you man,
it's hard to hit nate Diaz.
Clean Heart and clean.
He's tall,
he's slick.
He just moves a lot.
You know?
It's hard because it's.
His range is good.
He's also good at ducking under shit.
You know,
he's good at anticipating here,
you know?
Yeah.
It could be interesting.
I think man,
if nate diaz got to like a serious
Moitai camp and really learn how to kick
correctly,
made more distance and then through the
occasional fucking take down attempt in
there.
You know,
I think with a lot of these guys,
one of the issues is they got a great
formula and that formula is winning
fights and it can,
it can carry them very far,
but is it the best strategy?
The best strategy is the guy you're
fighting.
It doesn't have any idea what the fuck
you're about to do.
That's the George St Pierre Strategy.
George would just mix it up so well and
it was like one of his best assets.
You really didn't know what his attack
was going to be with these guys.
Like,
you know,
what their tax can it be with nate and
notice attack's going to be.
But it's a fucking good attack.
It's a good attack.
But I think we're seeing the changing of
the guard.
You're,
you're seeing these athletes like luke
rockhold is just a freak.
Conor mcgregor,
these guys who can do it all.
So you have the old guard with,
you know,
I'm not,
I'm not hating on these guys,
but I was one of the old guards.
I like to,
uh,
you know,
wrestle box,
didn't do a lot of kickboxing,
knew a lot of kicks.
You look at Rashad Evans,
really not kickboxer good at wrestling,
good at box,
and we know who's gonna bring to the
table.
He's got a big head kick knock out.
And Sean Salmon,
that's like one of his true biggest
highlight reel for sure.
But,
but how long ago was that?
Long time ago.
You would've thought that that would
have been a bigger part of his arsenal.
He can do.
He's athletic enough.
You Ain't get a guy like Ryan Bader
wrestler box,
so you have this old guard.
The new guys coming up,
man,
if you don't have it all good luck and
they're.
And they're tossing these guys up who
are phenomenal fighters.
They have these huge,
a fan base and stuff like that and
they're,
they're giving it to these young
athletic guys and good luck with that.
Would that would that skillset,
man?
It's.
I think it's,
this sport is just still evolving and
we're in the middle of it and we're
watching it happen,
but it's still all over the place.
It's still like your weight class is a
perfect example.
Your weight class,
you cannot be one dimensional.
You can close.
There's no one you can't do it.
It's not.
It's not an option.
There's no one who one dimensional.
Who's anywhere near the top 10 where you
have maybe out of the top five say for
me the most one dimensional or pseudo.
Yeah.
But are they really,
you know,
for me it gives us amazing ground guy,
but he tries to kick box everybody's so
who knows the wrestler,
but he's trying to punch a hole in your
head.
So fucking striking is not bad.
So who does try our very sharp slow for
the weight class,
but he's so strong and he does negate
the gap very well.
So I think that he takes care of his
lack of speed,
but then you fight someone like
Demetrius where everything is about
speed.
So that's where I think he's still too
slow to beat demetrious.
It's going to be an interesting fight.
It's going to be a real interesting
fight.
I mean,
you're talking about a guy was a Olympic
gold medalist and wrestling and he's a
motherfucker with his mindset,
his mind.
He mean he is a winter,
so who was just a straight up wait up
winter.
All those Olympic athletes that come
into the UFC,
they were all pretty successful.
Man.
They think about them.
You Got Dan Henderson a DC,
so huda off obviously Ronda Rousey.
You've got all that Olympic mindset,
man.
The.
It's priceless.
Do you remember?
Yes.
It was like,
hello everybody.
If they're lucky,
wake the whole division.
So lucky that he had a good wrestling
wrestling,
a teaching Gig coaching and they got a
good offer.
If people.
He didn't want him to,
they wouldn't let him fight in the UFC.
Was the Brigham Young.
I think that's what he was with and they
were like,
you can't fight in the UFC.
He can't fight cage fighting while
you're teaching wrestling,
not byu son.
They're so lucky because of that
motherfucker got in there.
He looked at every single thing about
somebody like Yoel Romero said,
you've seen him get taken down.
Yeah,
you can take a stand up.
Stand up holding me down with Jesus on
my side and change the way you hold him
down.
It's drug test.
So screwed.
Oh,
I don't want.
I don't mean this flip scripts there,
but how about bisbing Anderson Silva?
I was blowing your phone up during that
man.
That was first of all.
Biz being is one of the toughest man on
the planet.
That dude has one eyeball.
Okay.
One knocked out bed.
The end of the third round came back,
won the fourth document.
The guy's blind in one eye.
I don't know that they don't bring
people to see something.
Say something,
but it's.
It's a.
because we were reading the teleprompter
and he's.
It's difficult.
It's like that.
I is,
I guess at certain angles he's got a
hold of.
I certainly because it's kind of tunnel
vision.
Oil in it.
Oil In the other.
I have a Zap.
Yeah,
and that's to protect the retina and
keep it in place is that they can attach
it yet because if they attach it,
it was a rip off again.
Yeah.
They attach it again.
It'll be more damaging,
so he has to wait until he's.
After he's done fighting,
they can read it.
So thinking about this,
he'd be interested in Silva with one I
Nelson's a south pole.
You fucked.
How crazy.
That is.
Crazy.
It's nuts man.
That flying to meet him.
Hi.
Yeah,
right.
But need that Anderson landed was
goddamn glorious.
Wouldn't he didn't kick.
He jumps up with the front leg or with
the right leg and then like there's all,
just like a pause in the air and then
back lizard.
He still had that ability to move,
like just kind of stare at you right
against the cage.
But then it was weird when he was in the
middle of the cage,
he didn't seem to want to throw.
It was so weird that you felt like he
had bisbing like especially the
beginning of the fourth round,
he could've capitalized and he was
hesitant.
He's 40.
Is that what it is?
He's 40,
40 year old man.
Can't just chalk that up like he's just
an older fighter man.
Phenomenal fighting natural.
Yeah.
And you know,
I mean bisbing was given them a ton of
shit saying you've been on steroids your
whole career.
Fair assumption.
We don't know if that's true or not
true.
We just know the one time he was tested,
he got caught.
Yeah.
That's.
So.
It's not like outlandish for Yasmin to
say that.
The one time out of competition testing
he got caught.
He knew who the fuck knows man.
It's hilarious when you look at his
trainer and he go,
purple man guys.
I mean he's,
I think he's in his sixties and I'm not.
I think he might be like 65,
66 years old or something like that.
Dick Veins have got more muscle than all
of us together.
We packed all my muscle together easily.
He looks like a cluster.
Of course.
Cox with fees so big.
He's so big.
So he's not natural.
Okay.
So if he's not natural than Anderson
knows about steroids,
he's heard of them.
He's the guy who was teaching him how to
lift weights and running them through
his strength
and conditioning program is 10 years
later.
Yeah.
Oh,
you know,
all these years you've been fighting.
This is stuff that I do.
It's probably not interesting for
recovery.
Super Person.
Super to super prison.
A sport that's like if you,
you know,
if you have your body moves better,
you don't get brain damage,
but that's not important that the
testing is super effective,
isn't it?
They're doing these guys.
Jeff Gate is a mother fucker and he's
not playing games.
He's trying to catch dudes.
He's showing up at your house at 6:00
in the morning and he's taking the piss
goal blood.
They got me the other day before I came
up here or know when I'm going to do a
podcast and they called me as I'm 10
minutes away,
five minutes away.
Where are you?
I'm in La.
I was like,
well,
you've got my gym.
Just wait for me.
I'll come back after the show.
No,
no,
we're coming to you,
bitch.
You fucking drove up to Danielle Lee's
house.
Yeah,
no,
to the way he does his podcast.
They watched me do the podcast after.
Tested me.
Super Nice people.
Very professional,
but they.
They're not fucking paying for
everything they touched for weed and
everything.
Everything.
Yeah,
but we doesn't matter.
Out of competition,
competition.
That doesn't.
Okay,
so let me ask you this.
Nor has coped by the way that was the
John Johnson voice.
So let me ask you this.
If,
if Nate Diaz,
Nate Diaz,
short notice fight.
Let's take the word out.
So let's say what you're going to say.
Let's say smoking weed.
He beats conor.
Yeah,
I,
I'm,
I'm sure.
Then you get flags.
It's a,
it's a Dq,
right?
It'd be a little contest if I smoked
weed to fight.
If I smoked weed today.
The fight is in two days or three days,
right?
If I smoked weed today and the day of
the fight,
I asked him,
would you test me?
I want to find out like what,
what the levels are.
I think I'd be okay.
I think you literally have to get high
the day before or the day of,
with the new parameters.
Oh really?
Yeah.
Well that's good then.
Yeah,
it's way different.
It's way different.
It's way different than it used to be.
So you have to.
It's not like trace,
they used to have trace amounts of thc,
but if I really believe that if I smoke
weed today and I ask them to test me on
Saturday,
I'd be okay.
The day of the fight though,
Huh?
Well Nick Diaz,
apparently Tomi was so tested,
so high that like this motherfucker had
to be high as fuck when he fought going
just saying just went out there.
Who pulls off a Gogo fucking Plata and
mma to Glorious and beautiful.
And after we got his cheek broken.
Yeah,
that's true.
You get hit with a bomb by going.
When can nate?
I'm can nick fight again in about nine
months.
I want to sit around.
They changed it around and was supposed
to be five years and they made it like a
year and a half I think is.
Oh,
they made it.
I think they made it 16 weeks shorter.
Yeah.
So it'd be an interesting fight.
Only because they fought before.
And Nick,
one surprise nick isn't calling Robbie
lawler out.
Well,
I don't think nick's callnote anybody
next just chilling out and waiting for
all this bullshit to settle.
He got fucking railroaded,
man,
because nick passed to Wida tests,
the really deep comprehensive blood
screens that they use for the Olympics.
He passed those with flying colors.
What?
He didn't pass it some bullshit ass
quest diagnostics lab test that the
fucking Nevada state athletic
commission,
Super,
Super Shady,
and these assholes wouldn't even pay
attention to the other two tests and
they tried to ban them for five years.
That's insane.
Assholes,
man.
That bat vandelay Silva things.
Another example,
assholes.
Assholes.
Where they did the vandelay banned him
for life.
That's booked.
Ventilator signed with bell door.
Yep.
But so abilities he did see today,
is it breaking news and Shit.
Damn,
I didn't know that,
but here's the deal.
We talked on the last podcast and Bill
Wanderlei Silva eventually has to fight
fader or first he's gonna fight fader or
first that's the big fight in Japan or
Japan,
but the having that fight in Japan could
throw his whole beltour deal in jeopardy
because he's going to have to find on
Indian casinos once he fights,
which at vandelays age is probably not
the worst thing in the world anyway
because it's good and juicy.
There's certain guys probably will
actually.
There's certain guys that only fight in
certain places and they look
ridiculously muscular.
Now.
I don't know exactly how everything
works,
but I know for Brazil,
but I know that.
Well that's,
that's even more shit.
That's even Australia only please.
The,
um,
the thing is they don't have a Jeff
Levitsky at Bella tour.
They don't have a fucking a hawk.
Nor do they want one.
No,
they don't want one.
You don't want the UFC.
Like what am I trying to do?
What are you trying to do here?
You fucking move on with our alumni,
but you're dealing with the commission
to missions easy.
Oh,
enforced this.
Not the commissioner.
This is the UFC is I did like the
commission.
Look,
it's a famous line that someone made up.
I don't know who it was,
but they said that passing one of those
urine test is an intelligence test.
It's not a drug test.
Correct.
It might've been a Victor Conte might've
been victor contact,
but he,
you know,
who's the bulk Ho guy who if anybody
fucking knows,
he knows.
So I think,
uh,
I,
I think vandelay well,
first of all,
I think they should fucking vandelays
suspension should be exactly as long as
it would have been if he got popped,
which I think is nine months at the
time.
Was it,
was it back then when he got caught?
Was it nine months?
Back then?
It was nine months.
Yeah.
If you test positive nine months,
so he's good.
He should be done.
This suspension should be over,
find them a little bit and let's move
on.
Man.
The guy never tested positive once.
Manderlay positive ones,
Napa,
her vandelay probably definitely did
something.
I mean,
you look at when he was fighting in
Japan,
but Japan didn't have tests or if they
did have tests,
they didn't care.
You know,
they,
they look mean incident.
This is coming straight from ensign.
Anyway.
Who said it was on his contract that we
will
not test you for steroids?
Ensign is incapable of lying.
He does not lie.
Chocolate l talked about it.
He said he took a piss test.
I was like walking around and just put
it on the back.
Just throw up and toilet.
He was like,
I'm not going to set it on the table.
There's no one around like just
wherever.
Then they just want to check.
Check it out.
Here's a sharpie.
Draw your name on it.
Please just write negative on it now.
Whatever you want,
whenever you want.
Right?
Healthy.
Either way,
awesome to not drink.
That's how you came back.
Do not drink,
but you know,
man,
it was,
it was.
Everybody knew.
You know,
if you have a league where everybody
knows that everybody else is doing
whatever the fuck they want,
that's a different thing.
It's not really cheating because it's
not illegal over there.
It's not the same thing as over here.
You just can't do that and be a legit
sport.
You know?
You just can't.
Baseball powerlifting,
excuse me,
power lifting.
I'm going to get so much hate for this.
I'm talking about a mainstream sport,
bro.
Don't ever,
ever,
ever.
Could you look at MBA,
strict drug testing,
NFL,
mlb not super strict.
There's fucking no home runs anymore.
People look like if bodybuilding and
power lifting if 100 percent,
it was legit across the board.
No steroids whatsoever.
Knocking on your door every morning at
4:00
AM,
they would all look like they look like
in Speedo with no one would look at the
sixties.
60 bodybuilders and power lifters,
legs.
Especially the bodybuilders.
Their legs are actually kind of small.
No.
They look good like they look like no,
they look how they just all do this and
they're in their high waisted tights and
they just hired.
There's certain guys from the
bodybuilding era of like Schwartzenegger
that to this day they look small but
yoked to sock like Frank Zane,
like Frank Zane.
He's never looked like Lee Haney or any
Dorian Yates or woman was three.
What?
Three whole muscle.
There was a guy like five,
nine.
That's insane.
Isn't running short.
Running coma.
It was like six something.
Six to which one is really short.
Dorian Yates.
I thought this Dorian pretty good.
Back in the day,
like before they started doing a lot of
steroids.
Like what?
Well,
who did pumping iron gains?
The guy's last name is Kenton.
I knew him and I spoke to him.
He said that was.
There was a black guy and featured and
pumping are,
and I can't remember his name,
but Albert Bekos a really muscular guy.
Yeah.
He was eating 20 pounds of red meat a
day and that's how he was getting.
He was like,
lions eat a lot of meat.
Second Dave is eating bro.
Science.
God Damn.
It literally me that a body.
But he was shredded though.
He was shy,
but you're not lying,
Huh?
Like what?
He would eat rice,
a large colonies.
Rice and 20 pounds of red meat to tell
them that gorillas only broccoli.
Yeah.
Right,
right.
All they eat is fucking go to the zoo.
They're eating stalks of broccoli and
bamboo,
but their dicks are this big.
So it's true.
That's true.
He was shredded in the,
in the,
um,
he's.
Did you see his dick because it was it a
big,
but it was tasty,
tasty fruit and those were the days
because it was arnold in Venice Beach,
Gold's gym collages everywhere.
Dick Frank Columbo was.
He was in class.
Franco Columbo.
Super Short.
Yeah.
That Franco Columbia used to be able to
take one of those hot water bottles and
his lungs were so strongly would make it
explode.
He would blow into it until it blew up.
I fucking hot water bottle.
One of those rubber things that nobody
else could do it,
but very few people could do it.
What in the fuck?
He do dips.
He would do dips with M,
two dudes hanging off his waist and he
would do dips.
And how about let's grab some weights,
know what he looks like today.
Remember plats member as well as you can
see it on youtube.
He's,
he's squat deep squat 500 pounds.
I think it was 25 times.
Those guys were doing it back then
though.
Oh yeah.
Lifting weights,
hanging everything on the beach time,
smoking weed,
banging chicks.
Tons of chicks letting guys below them
so they have money for steroids.
Good chance.
A good chance was going on.
That was a big thing with those
bodybuilder.
Yeah.
The big thing there.
The original sugar babies.
I'm dead serious,
man.
He's such a great word.
Bodybuilders with original sugar,
baby.
Well,
you got to do what you gotta do.
Lift and pay the bill or suck a dick.
You got two options.
You want muscles,
son?
Come here.
Come on.
You want to hang out with your boys on
the beach,
but I like this Dick.
Imagine steroids didn't work,
but sucking Dick did be the only way to
get swoll yet a suck a dick.
Calvin would be the biggest motherfucker
in the room.
Tam,
right?
I wouldn't change what gay.
They would change it.
Oh,
I'm not gay because I like Dick's.
I'm just trying to get big.
Get big.
Get big guys would take brewer's yeast
back in the day.
Do you remember that?
Oh Dude,
I knew guys who were just always
lifting.
They'd go check this out.
I'd be like,
why?
Why would it take now?
Apparently brewer's yeast makes you
bigger school that's super and sell it
in pill form.
You don't remember that?
No.
Just because didn't stick because you
guys are older.
When steroids hit,
they didn't think it was as bad as it
was.
Right.
Like a WHO's at Laila as NATO was kind
of the first one who's like,
oh,
I'm going to die because I use steroids
before it wasn't a big deal.
It's kind of like cigarettes,
right?
See Blind.
Well,
Zeto I don't think it was because of
that.
I think would lozito was doing.
He was doing an early form of human
growth hormone.
I might be off base here.
Jamie.
Jamie wanted to say though,
but the early form of human growth
hormone was taken from cadavers.
It wasn't taken.
It wasn't made in a lab with bacteria.
The way they make growth hormone today
in the early form of human growth
hormone,
you would take it and there was like
crazy adverse side effects like people
got really fucked up that you don't get
fucking Jacob Crooks felt you can get
mad cow disease from him from it.
You get all kinds of data.
Was saying that he was dying because of
that and then scientists came out or
like,
no son,
I don't think he has a brain tumor.
It was,
well,
you know,
you also got to deal with the massive
amount of trauma.
That guy played football for hard,
hard maybe.
Who knows?
There's all sorts of bad things happen
to your brain when you play football for
30 years.
I mean,
especially the way he did football back
then was different.
Who knows why,
kind of why he got brain,
but here's the thing.
Not a lot of other guys that were doing
what he did.
God brain tumors,
so it could have been completely
unrelated.
You just don't.
They say that human growth hormone,
from what I understand is so it's going
to help grow everything.
That's good,
but also if you have a tumor cell to
help grow that,
it could.
It's potentially a,
that is potentially a side effect,
you know,
that's why one of the things they say
that's really important than if you,
if you do do that,
you gotta get yourself scanned and if
you're doing it like the way those guys
are doing and where you're taking like
10 units a day,
you know,
they've taken mass.
That's why the bodybuilders show big and
they have those,
those power guts.
Guts.
Yeah.
Yeah man.
Well it,
it,
it's like these bulging muscles too.
That's the other thing,
like if you have those gigantic like Lee
Haney,
ab muscles,
you've got to think of his whole body.
Everything's giant.
Everything's trying,
so his ab muscles are giant too.
They,
they stick out also because there is
Oregon,
Oregon to.
Because a greater deck apparently.
No Sir.
If you do take massive amounts for long
periods of time,
it can grow your organs larger,
but I think what we're looking at and
where you're looking at those guys,
a lot of it is just massive muscle.
I agree.
It's the more Muslim than we've ever
seen because you look at even arnold
site gets a different game and when I
was doing it was just basically just
steroids.
Yeah.
And now they're doing all these designer
drugs.
They sweat nonstop.
I don't know if you've hung out with the
current bodybuilder.
They sweat.
Not Straight up dying.
There are always dying straight up
dining.
Dorian and Lee Haney was very tough.
From what I understand,
it wasn't me.
Well if Lee Haney six feet tall,
looks like Dorian's someone on send main
it a glorious.
He's an orange line.
Glorious main.
He's an orange.
He's Donald Trump.
It looks like Donald Trump.
If Donald,
isn't it?
Isn't it weird how they turn bronze
because black guys,
right?
They're like fucking see every muscle.
So white dudes like,
dude,
we got to get black.
The original original like chocolate
face.
The guys that really dark.
Yeah,
they'll,
there'll be,
they'll have a white face and then the
rest of them.
So dark black,
straight,
black,
Jamaican.
Yeah.
Because they want to compete with the
black guy.
Yeah.
Just to show contrast.
Muslim guys own bodybuilding.
Now,
do they own it now,
Phil Heath?
Five time.
Mr Olympia champion.
Before that,
well it was Jay Cutler,
but then you have Ronnie Coleman for all
those years.
Dexter Jackson.
I don't know how long you could do that
for it to take that much steroids at
that high level.
How long was the most eight?
I think eight is the most.
Six.
I think you already do it.
How many years at Arnie?
When Arnie was.
He was doing it right and then he just
blew the fuck up and went full
celebrity.
It was like,
you know what,
I'm going to quit fucking lifting
weights with you mean hit.
I think go make some money.
Phil Heath wants to do.
He wants to get 10 titles and then quit.
That's like a good number.
I was like,
yeah.
The problem with those guys is what do
they do when it's over?
They showed um,
some of the guys from the old days that
are still alive today and they get off
the sauce and their body just depressed
kidneys are,
wouldn't they have to keep doing it to,
to fill the gap in their body.
So gonna have to do something,
some form of testosterone,
but the kidneys is from the weight
cutter.
Yeah.
Unless the kidneys is not from steroids.
The kidneys is from the massive
dehydration.
When you see those guys and they're
standing on that scale or not scale on
that stage and they're posing,
they're down to like three percent body,
close to death,
close to death.
They'll carb,
no water,
no carbs.
Their bodies are just like,
if you try and talk to one,
well when they're getting ready for
that,
it's the brain barely functions because
they're just so depleted.
They know how to.
It's so dangerous,
man.
So dangerous.
Well,
now they manipulate their insulin to.
They do all kinds of stuff that's
dangerous.
Pumping iron.
No generation.
Iron generation generation.
I.
Yeah.
Netflix,
I'm sure.
Yup.
With Kai Greene Guy Green car green.
Who is a giant.
He's a giant gay.
He's not gay.
Whoa Bro.
How dare you.
Sorry.
Green is a guy.
We were talking gay for pay.
There's videos out there of him fucking
grapefruits for money.
Right?
But it might,
it might.
It might be a cantaloupe,
but he's doing some case stuff.
He's like stripping for men.
It's all over the Internet.
Gay Porn didn't know.
Hey man,
why do you say that?
Feel like he knows he did it.
Why he shouldn't.
He's awesome.
He puts on the mask,
the mask and posts and subways.
He's second.
He comes in second to Phil Heath every
year.
And think one of the reasons why he
doesn't win this because he has this
history of doing some promiscuous stuff
with men like this.
There's a video of him stripping,
like shoves the winning.
Uh,
I can't compete.
They should let them win the to never
win when it comes in second,
that's really.
Look at his hair.
That bond in the back of his head as
adorable.
Amazing.
Maybe that's the offensive part of that.
I'm like,
is the hair,
is the,
oh,
look at this.
What's going on there guys there?
And they're big rivals.
By the way,
Phil Heath.
Boy,
they are both enormous.
You know,
here's the problem.
When it gets down to this,
like these two guys,
how the fuck do you decide who wins?
How could you even our semester,
do you tell your account?
Is it.
Well,
you can because you're a good wine
connoisseur.
It's like the same thing.
It's symmetry.
Do you know a great glass of wine?
The tannins and the cookie flavor A.
I don't get how they do it either.
It's symmetry.
You're looking at muscle development,
but you're also looking at symmetry.
Okay,
we'll see.
But they all look like that,
but these two guys,
they're in different stages of the pose.
Like the guy on the left,
his arms are further apart now.
No one chose that pose and the other
chose.
He feel he poses right,
but see how kai greene forgot about his
legs.
Phil said,
I'm gonna.
Open my legs a little bit.
Look at those.
Look at the leg.
Must look at that.
That's perfect and insane.
He's perfectly proportional.
You Know Phil played basketball in
college and it was 178 pounds pointguard
and he's got to be like 300 pounds.
Good Buddy of mine,
man from Denver.
Yeah.
Going really well.
How long is he going to do this for?
He said,
he said he wants 10 times,
this is his fifth.
He wants 10,
so five more years in his body like
Jesus Christ.
[inaudible] making,
making that Cheddar though.
Is he making seven figures you.
How do they do that?
How do they make that fun?
Because uh,
yeah,
so who,
who go to England,
who do all these big uh,
programs,
you know,
who knows,
do all these big pro ams and get paid
bank like over in Europe and the Middle
East.
Bodybuilding huge Europe.
Yeah.
Huge way bigger than it is here.
Two hundred $50,000
to win $400.
$200.
But then in sponsor she's making six,
seven figures.
It's interesting how much it jumped up
for 2015.
We went from 250,
two to 75 to 400.
He's got,
he's got his own line.
He's got his own supplement line.
Doesn't think that that's pretty well,
yeah,
I called gifted nutrition,
but I don't think it's.
I don't think that he's not making his
money off,
that he's making money doing these tours
and go like he gets on with Olympia and
literally two days later he's flying to
the Middle East,
said he's coming in England.
He said he's gone 300 days a year.
Yeah,
nuts.
Well,
seminars are a big wave for a lot of
athletes to make money,
including MMA guys.
A lot of guys make a lot of their money.
A lot of Jujitsu guys make a lot of
their money.
Especially.
Yeah.
Especially as huge and Jujitsu is one of
the few seminars where you could really
get something out of it.
I agree.
You know,
if you go to see a Moitai seminar,
you might learn a little bit.
I mean you could,
but a lot of people know a lot about
more time.
More ties is like repetition,
knowledge,
sparring,
great coaching over long periods of
time.
But Jujitsu,
a guy could show you one technique and
you could tap different sex or
something.
Yeah.
It's pretty eyeopening thing like,
Woo.
I was watching your boys sideboard role.
He was doing some drills the other day.
God Damn,
that guy flows.
Ooh,
freak man.
He was doing this,
this role from,
from controlling on top side control to
the truck,
to the back to,
you know,
taking like a collar choke from behind.
Crazy.
How moves.
Oh my God.
If he's doing that,
he's invitation.
Is that right?
I think he's doing super fun.
Hope he is.
I hope he is.
I'm pretty sure he's doing a superfight
well.
That whole Eddie Bravo invitation and
when they're going to do the open weight
like anybody can compete the absolute.
That's going to be amazing.
It's gonna be nuts.
Oh my God.
I know on.
It's doing one of one 65 and under at
Don.
At Academy in Austin.
March.
Yeah,
March 24th and I are doing the play by
play for that.
Are you really with a Jujitsu Guy?
Yeah,
I was going to say hopefully because I'm
going to probably do the Jujitsu play,
but for sure who you guys.
I'm going to have some travel.
Someone who's running the thing on it.
Got Them.
Do you know who the judges would play
but I don't.
I,
I asked him todd white lives in on it.
Maybe it'd be him to be fun though.
Fuck yeah,
yeah.
Jujitsu tournament to the future.
I really think so.
And I think one of these platform.
Yeah,
I think one of the cool things about it
too is that,
you know,
definitely get injured,
definitely get broken bones and stuff,
but you're not,
you couldn't compete it and not worried
about head trauma,
you know,
so I think a lot of people that are
interested in martial arts are
gravitating towards that because they're
realizing now like,
hey,
like a,
this is probably,
there's not a lot of options if you want
to learn how to fight,
where you're not going to get your brain
rattled.
There's so many.
There's such a debate now like in
Europe,
especially about kids playing rugby and
any kind of girl.
You're up in America.
I mean it's a very real thing where
doctors and academics are going.
Hold on.
Like I know it's a great sport,
but you are talking about,
you are talking about head trauma to
your 14 year old.
That's a fact.
Whether what that's gonna do to him
later down the line,
we don't know America is,
chances are you'll probably be fine when
you're talking about someone who's so
young that they don't really understand
the repercussions of their current
actions.
And if you're doing something at 14 that
might affect you when you're 44,
that's kind of crazy,
you know?
Yeah.
But then yet again,
this is a lot of people that play
football and they're fine at 44.
So you know,
a lot of people play for four years.
I don't know about all that.
I don't know about that.
Most of those guys are fucked up.
They're just fucked up.
But not if you played in high school.
We played in high school due to a lot of
people that they've tested that are high
school,
cte,
cte.
A lot of them are finding more and more
sure.
And I'm sure it causes damage,
but what I'm saying is that it's not as
though I don't think the epidemic of
people that play football.
Like if you said,
well,
most people would played football even
in high school,
you know,
have brain damage.
I bet they do.
Compared to people who didn't.
Yeah,
not only that.
Here's the thing.
There's things like you can be high
functioning,
but you can also have like real impulse
problems and a lot of those real impulse
problems are created by head trauma,
depression.
Here's a question.
Will lash out anger issues.
A matter of fact,
one of the things that Oj Simpson's
doctor said that if they were doing that
same trial today when he was tried for
murder,
they would probably bring up.
See,
see?
Yeah.
But here's the question.
When you know,
if you're going to ban and it's just,
it's out there,
but if you're going to band combat
sports for kids,
well you know,
you wonder like what?
You get a lot of benefit from sports
that are rough as well in a way you
know,
in how it builds character or it's just
a sport you might be built for and
you're really good at it.
So if you're,
if you're built like a Samoan and maybe
soccer isn't going to be as good for you
as football.
So in a way you've got to be careful
with this stuff.
You need some of this stuff.
Well,
it's definitely good to toughen people
up.
It's definitely.
I mean there's no,
no better avenue to teach people
discipline and how to be tough than
combat sports.
I think combat sports is,
you know,
it's the one thing where you have to
figure out how to,
how to actually get it done.
There's no,
there's no maybes.
There's no close.
There's no.
You get it done.
No one's helping you.
No one's helping you by yourself.
Yeah.
You enter into that ring is a referee in
there.
Guys just saved your life.
That's it.
And then there's another dude and he
weighs the same as,
you know,
like taekwondo,
you guys get knocked down and kicked and
stuff,
but you get a lot out of getting better
at something,
you know,
especially when the stakes are high.
You certainly do.
But I think that if I had to do it all
over again,
like if I knew what I know now and I
went back and it was involved in
striking sports,
I'd be way more careful.
Way More careful about head kicks.
Know I kinda got lucky and dodged a lot
of trauma,
but I know a lot of people who didn't.
A lot of a lot of kickboxers who just
fought for nothing.
I enough.
I remember I thought it was cool when
they'd go 30 seconds left in the whole
gym would turn and watch me and Shannon
Cohen plant our feet and just slug each
other in the head and we get done like
high five.
They're not getting my cons.
Throw up chase and Shane would call me
and go,
dude,
I forgot where I was going and at the
time were like,
gods you tomorrow.
See You tomorrow.
Meet head power.
Then we get in our cars and do it again.
The next day.
I remember playing football in college
and there's a play called 96 power and
then you'll bring in the shop bringing
in the shop.
I'd come in,
it was me versus giant linebacker named
Brian [inaudible] who was a second round
or third round draft.
Pick a nightmare and I take a running
start and we'd run into each other and
everyone wait and stop.
That was my thing and I think of it not,
hey man,
I'm the front guy.
If it's the civil war,
I'm the guy in the front of the idiot.
Watch this.
He sounds simone and simone.
No,
black is nine from Houston,
Texas.
Close though,
right?
It makes you rethink things you've done
obviously in your past.
I look at earlier parts of my career,
all of my training,
I have a good chin.
Granted I fight child size grownups,
but the the lollipop guild
attacking you is another big of a deal,
but you will learn.
You fucking like Linux or Linux.
He hit me.
It's fucking hard and I remember
everything in the ring going Funky,
like fuck,
don't attack me right now.
That hurt you.
I've been hit a lot.
I put myself in the,
in the hospital snowboarding,
hitting my head,
you know?
I've definitely had some brain that I
wouldn't trade it though.
Yeah,
I wouldn't trade it for the one that I
would train different.
Exactly.
You guys are both okay right now.
Like you're not Muhammad Ali,
Joe Frazier in his the later years.
I think by the time you get old,
they're gonna,
have some shit worked out,
they're going to stick a fucking syringe
and your brain scored some stem cells in
there and you're going to be good to go.
So I'm pretty sure.
I'm pretty sure they're,
they're getting real close.
I mean they're getting real close to
reengineering the entire human frame.
They're getting so close to every day
that moved one step closer,
but then 20,
30 years they're gonna have some cures
for all kinds of shit.
The problem is when you're already like
at Muhammad Ali's stage or Freddie
Roach,
game over.
Yeah.
Freddie Roach has functional
Parkinson's.
That's from trauma and you know,
he,
he's open about it.
He was in war.
You watch this old fights.
That's why he stops fight sooner now.
Yep.
He's smart about it because he goes,
I wish my coach would have stopped the
fight sooner.
So now what was his last flight?
It was cody's like,
I'm going to stop that.
You've got one more ram.
I'm going to stop this.
Well,
the guy who fought Cova love.
What's his face?
The,
um,
uh,
the uh,
Canadian guy,
Pascal,
yes.
Sean,
John Pascoe who was just getting box was
doing nothing.
Well,
he was getting the therapy and go,
you know,
I think the first fight took a shitload
out of him and that's something that
people do not want to admit when you
take the kind of beating that he took in
that first fight in the first fight,
arguably was called a hair soon.
But the,
but it's a hair mean.
His argument was that it was called two
students.
Got a great chance he should have been
able to fight.
He tagged him a few times.
She could have won that fight.
He did tag them a few times,
but he didn't tag him a few times.
And that second find that second five
was the coal Kovalev show.
It wasn't even close,
straight up asked weapon.
He's a bad motherfucker.
Fucking scary murder to murder.
He's in and out.
He's fluid and you know what he likes to
do for a strength and conditioning
palladium movement.
Coach milady's does a lot of.
He's one of the hot ass in there.
He's trying to.
And in his wife,
the way you,
if you look at his body,
I don't know how he hits that heart is
perfect technique,
long,
long limbs and doing it for everybody.
It's like the body is one thing,
but the skeleton is the big skeleton is
a giant part of how a guy can punch and
the size of the hands,
the shape of the shoulders.
It's a huge,
huge factor.
What makes connor so good?
Look at KCI shoulders.
His shoulders or dude,
I'm a huge man.
I think he weighed at one 70,
71 78 right now he's,
he's,
he's that this week to make 70.
How about chocolate?
Chocolate.
Dell.
He used to get us.
He'd get measured and he'd hold his
shoulders in.
So it said he was 76 inches when he's
really 79 and he was standing next to
you and I was looking at what they do
that because he wanted.
He didn't want you to know how long has
reached out to Dick.
Fuck yeah,
come on.
We'll tell them to do that.
So,
so that it says it reached 76 and if all
of a sudden it comes out with 79 inches
and he's jabbing you or whatever he's
doing,
but you know,
I looked at him and,
and how,
how wide his shoulders were and how big
he's walking around at 2:30.
Right.
Motherfucker.
Yeah.
He's been talking crazy shit about Jon
Jones.
Just wait until he slaps you John's or a
chuck's big hands reaching the Gaza
table lamp.
You're like,
what?
Yeah,
he thinks he would give Jon Jones
trouble right now.
He's a fighter.
He'll do it.
It's just that idea of fighter.
That's this thing in his head.
I mean he's,
he's still hits the bag and you know,
he still has power and he still thinks
that if he.
I think his exact words were,
if I hit him right now,
if I put my hands on him,
I'd give him trouble.
He said his style would give John Fritz.
Yeah.
And he said that John wouldn't be able
to out wrestle him,
which was like,
that's tough.
It's tough.
Well,
what are you going to say?
The guy.
The guy's a fucking legend.
I can't disrespect.
He's retired and he been in some crazy
ass wars and it's over.
He's earned that.
So it's.
He's earned the right.
Yeah.
He's earned the right to talk some shit.
And you know,
John John had to respond a little bit,
but either way employed John responded
was actually pretty kind.
Yeah.
You know,
he said maybe if truck fought a little
smarter.
We protected his chin.
He also just put,
oh,
chuck class.
That is going to be fun.
Him and Cormier.
You too.
So it's going to be very fun.
Did you see the photoshops?
Yes.
So tyrone and funny super funny TV show.
No,
no.
That fucking circle.
Yes.
No,
it's the same guy,
but that's from die hard.
Yeah.
So when he's a cop.
So funny.
What's your weight back and forth to
each other and love it.
What do you guys think of a home tape?
It's a good fight.
It's a different fight.
Holly Holm,
first of all,
is she's first of all,
without a doubt,
the best striker in that fucking
division.
No one moves like her knew her
athleticism,
her footwork or kicks in,
you know,
the way she's conservative with that
head kick to.
She waits till she knows it's time and
then Bob,
she doesn't waste time on it.
I can just throw it into the calculator.
She lands it.
That's fucking step to neck.
Oh so,
so good.
And if you look at our highlight reel,
it's all that in other smaller
organizations with UFC.
But misha tate fights with a lot of
pressures.
Toughest Shit.
Her grappling is really good.
Super Gritty.
She's reading,
she's got singles and doubles.
We just close the door she's got.
But here's one thing she has to do.
She,
she can't run in like what Rhonda did is
play right into the strengths of holly.
Holly's a fantastic counter striker and
Rhonda just wanted to overwhelm her with
pressure and power and take her out.
And she got cracked early and often and
by the end of the first round she was
like seeing tweety birds and all kinds
of shit.
She probably had no idea what the fuck
was going on.
Me.
She's not going to fight like that.
She is not,
she can't,
she's going to fight hands up high and
she's gonna,
she's gonna fight more conservative and
I keep going into the Raquel Pennington
flight,
which was holly's first fight in UFC,
which she won a very close split
decision and it's not taking anything
away from Raquel because Raquel is a bad
ass bitch.
All due respect.
To recap,
you'll see jitter son.
Yeah,
UFC jitters are a big factor.
I think that probably played a big
factor,
but also raquel's just real tough and
real smart and you know,
didn't rush in.
I think the rushing.
In fact there was a big part of that
fight.
Ronda just charging straightforward like
fucking wild animal and then holly
moving and craft the worst.
And what do you do with a technician?
What do you do?
You make it a fricking gritty fight.
That's what mister blancher and I don't
know if she's gonna win that clench.
She's not going to get for her to shoot
a double or a single from that distance.
You're going to get sprawled on.
You can training be a.
no one's taken holly down.
You have no one's taken it down,
but you can get.
You look at the previous three fights in
the UFC.
People can get her to the cage,
but then then you got an a clench and I
think holly is stronger than me.
Misha,
I mean it's going to take over her.
Well,
I don't know about the wrestling aspect
stronger.
I mean she hits harder,
but my friend Justin,
Justin Milo,
Suzanne Brown belt,
you know,
division one wrestler,
serious fucking athlete.
He said that holly feels like a dude.
He said he rolled with both of them.
You both enrolled with holly and with
Rhonda and he's like,
there's no comparison.
It's like holly as strong as fuck.
See it?
He's like,
she's really strong.
I think holly winds.
I just think it's a different fight.
It's a tougher fight for holly.
The different puzzle to figure it out.
It's all about match ups.
Yeah,
I don't.
I don't think that she gets destroyed
like Rhonda did.
I don't think she gets out class like
Rhonda did.
I think it's a closer fight,
but holly still comes out on top.
Well,
you know,
the other thing is that holly went
through camp for Rhonda,
like no camp.
Chevron went through before and she said
she trained so fucking hard for that and
you see the results of that.
I think she's going to do the exact same
thing for this camp.
So if she goes into this fight with that
same kind of training camp behind her
and it's just in fucking phenomenal
shape.
Like she was for Ronda Rousey,
which she is.
She might box that shit out.
There's more pressure on holly now
because we exchanged there to be,
you know,
she's this,
it's not a one time thing.
She wasn't a one trick pony.
She wants to just a flash in the pan.
I think for her there's more pressure to
perform now.
Rhonda,
she was such a big underdog.
He's like,
Eh,
she wasn't getting mercked beats the
fuck out of it.
Now we're like,
damn polly's for reals now there's
pressure on her.
Maybe.
Maybe,
but she's happy.
She's in 19.
Type this my man.
What about women's boxing lot?
When's the thing we watched it exactly.
It's in the high school auditorium.
A big deal for her though.
She's still there.
Not saying that you're not doing press
counter.
You're not the champion.
You don't have everyone ready how he's
ready for this,
but another thing is taking pressure off
is that most people are paying attention
to connor for this fight,
for this fight.
They're talking to her a little bit.
Percent is the condom mcgregor show.
Let me ask you guys this question,
the rest of the car,
but this is a weird question.
Good fights will pull up the car at this
good fights is a great card.
He's not just a good car for those car
show though.
It's the connor show,
but let's pull up this car.
Jamie.
There's a fucking bunch of good fights
on this car.
No,
here's one that everyone's sleeping on.
Amanda Nunez.
That is the dark horse as the division
friends.
Amanda Nunez is a fucking knockout
machine.
She is tough as fuck.
Right.
Stretching she's taken on is Valentina.
She's a chick who was tough as fuck too,
and a multiple time world Moitai fight
for it.
Let's calm down on that.
A posture though,
Hon.
Valentino.
No,
she's Russian Bros.
That's true.
You've goT a fucking dumb shit.
Excuse me.
Curgas.
Amanda,
as soon as I mentioned he has is so
athletic and her striking.
She's bad ass.
She's a bucking hard.
She's fit.
She hits fucking hard.
I watched that.
Sara mcmann fight again.
She's got a listing of a right hand.
She might be the biggest one.
Punch striker in that division.
She's tough as fuck,
but You know,
you look at her and then you look at the
entire division.
I think it's this.
This fight is a big fight for her
because valentina,
she also went through her ufc jitters.
She was like real stiff and awkward and
she was telling herself that in between
rounds in her first fight.
I don't think she's going to be like
that.
Coming into this fight.
Good striking.
Look.
Good.
Here's another fighter,
but he's sleeping on your boy.
Brandon thatch and bought her designer.
That's a good loser.
History papers you think so?
I wouldn't give either one of these guys
are walking papers.
You're not joseph.
They're both exciting to watch.
Fuck yeah.
These are great fighters.
I agree.
A car by her disease.
Yeah.
So he hasn't been almost two years time
off.
He got hurt.
What happened to them?
Do you not sure.
I know he got hurt and then thatches
lost two in a row,
but they're too short notice.
Fights get a change in gunner nelson and
they had to fight ben henderson.
YEah,
well he got clipped and the nelson fight
gunner surprised him with that left
hook.
That was a big punch and then submitted
them.
That was a big fight though,
man.
I'm telling you.
If people could see him in the gym,
it's like,
dude,
what the fuck is he too big here?
He's incredibly.
He's not too big.
He's always been a discipline issue for
him and it's always been izzy in the
fight because nico see you can't man.
You just can't have a night off and
beat.
Gunnar nelson.
You can't not be focused and being a
striking range of a top 10 or top 15,
you know,
guy and not get knocked out.
But in losing all that weight to get
down to one 70,
what does he walk around at?
He's a one 90.
That's it?
Yeah.
He's but shredded.
He looks so big.
No shredding.
He looks like he's a light heavyweight.
He's tall,
but he's thin,
but he has a lot of muscle.
Yeah,
I'm serious.
I look at him and he looks to me almost
like a light heavyweight.
One 85 I'm telling is not a light
heavyweight.
No,
I believe.
Yeah.
Well obviously he's fighting at one 70.
Makes it weight.
Yeah,
but you never seen a fight.
He does seem so relaxed before the
fight,
like it might be with the way he deals
with nerves,
but he's almost like talking to people
and he looks way more casual than most.
Holy shit.
Go back to that.
Grew up really early.
Pre jim miller and diego fucking
sanchez.
Was that a prelim fight?
That's early prelims.
That's son.
How is the.
Trying to get that ufC pass?
Trying to get everybody to buy ufc fight
pass and diego sanchez versus jim miller
is a great way to get that done.
My third fight of the night folks.
Ooh,
diego sAnchez is such a fucking
barbarian.
If that guy was put on this earth to do
one thing,
to go to war,
it's true.
He's such an animal that's doing.
don't sleep.
Don't sleep on their syllabus to leave.
Exactly.
That's another good fight.
That's a very good.
Nor dean to leaves a bad motherfucker
first team all body.
Eric silva fell off well.
Yeah.
He til he took his spot.
His body's changed a little bit.
Oh,
what at all?
Well,
I don't want to talk about it,
but he didn't lose his apple bottom and
he doesn't seem quite as shredded as
wonder If he would pass the smell test.
Yeah.
He was a shredded animal before.
Is it freaky looking at one point in
time?
He was ridiculous.
They probably a lot of flights.
Um,
I don't think so.
Dude.
I think he was.
I don't know what you're talking about.
There have been 20 pounds of red meat.
There was some stuff that he realized it
was clocking his colon.
He lives in a country where you can just
get that stuff.
Sure.
A lot of funny.
That gives a lot of capital.
Minerals.
Yeah.
I say when I say a lot of beef,
it's interesting watching all this
happen though,
isn't it?
Watched some guys bodies change.
Watching their performance has changed.
I like it because it doesn't make me
feel as bad about my body and I liked
the word as you're still the ufc
fighters as not as bad.
How about the.
How about the old police on telly,
but he's a stud stud.
Yeah.
Strangulations on your wrong
motherfucker.
No police.
Strong motherfucker.
Shop haircut.
He's 20 buddies from France.
I don't know if I can,
can get behind french.
Arabic text my boy.
He's arabic.
Who is noxious shit and just going to
bring up my friends.
I don't know man.
Who iS that guy that uh,
george st pierre brought in with him to
train these drugs.
My friend cigarettes.
Yeah,
the french moitai guy.
He's a bad motherfucker.
John something or another.
I forget his name.
I forget them too.
But on the ultimate fighter,
george told everyone,
man,
if you're sparring with this guy,
don't fucking hit him hard man.
PiSs them off.
We're gonna.
Be in trouble.
Yeah,
be nice.
Meanwhile,
he,
he has the ultimate dad bod that guys
that need a dad bod,
so dad by yellow cab looks like yellow
bass from cincinnati and who is this?
Who is this more thai champion that
george st pierre brought belly smokes
on.
Stuff that his name.
he was kicking the shit out of.
Smelled like booze.
He'd come in drunk.
Oh yeah.
He would come in drunk like up all night
partying.
Just going to eat like a title or the
dutch or the dutch or french apparently
to just all night in vegas.
GoIng to parties,
having a good time and then fucking
these young tough kids up during the
day.
You know what man,
all that crazy behavior that these guys
used to engage in,
you know,
can't get away with too many cell phones
these days.
Like if theSe guys are trying to do that
today,
trying to go out and johnny Manziel that
player,
he was a heisman winner.
First round draft pick.
The dude likes to party.
He likes to party so much.
Cleveland browns like,
yo,
if you party man,
we're going to cut you.
This fucking guy goes to vegas under a
hidden name and wears a wig and a
mustache.
He looks like everyone's like,
oh,
that's johnny manziel,
and then it goes online and cleveland
browns that is going to get cut.
He doeSn't do it with a mustache and me.
I'm telling you,
johnny manziel,
he partied with a.
Which is this the guy that's him.
He was a stud.
Football college,
partied in a blonde wig,
fake mustache glass.
How can they tell you you can't party.
This is what they can tell you.
Your performance was unsatisfactory.
Your cut.
That's what they can tell you.
They can't tell you.
You can't go and have a good time.
This was a problem.
Joe.
What?
He's partying every fucking night.
What have you.
Drinking water.
He just likes to dance,
so it's part of his cardio.
Now.
He haS.
he's actually an alcoholic.
He's been in and out of rehab.
If he's got a movement coach and
movement coach wants them to like you're
talking to step on the desk.
So that's how you fucking movement.
Coach troll.
The other day I was howling.
What did you say?
What was your exact quote you believe in
said,
if you think instance,
it was going to beat michael bisbing a
decision the uk.
Then you obviously believe in dragons
and moving coaches.
People got mad at you because they were
so mad.
They were like dragons exist to do.
There's Plenty of evidence now.
They got mad at a movement coach.
Thing is they think I'm hitting on
conor.
I'm not at all.
We're a port.
Wasn't a porto porto.
I'm not at all.
Not at all.
Connor's fans are the most fucking
easily,
but her people ever.
I talk so much shit on everybody else,
rhonda,
all this stuff and I get some stuff.
All I said about connor said,
hey,
guess what frankie edgar's coming for
you.
He didn't say anything.
Of course.
I had so many asshole fans.
I don't know what country they were from
or what,
but right Ireland,
buddy.
Fuck you.
You piece of shit.
They say,
fuck with two o's for.
Fuck you.
I've never had such an onslaught of f
just shit talking because I said that
you have a fight.
There's
an identity thing going on there.
They're identifying with thiS guy in a
way that you remember when you were a
kid and I don't know how it was with
you,
but when I was a kid I would identify
with a fighter fighter lost.
I was devastated and I remember that day
I let it go.
Donald curry for mike mccallum and I was
at giant tunnel curry fan man.
I love Donald Curry and mike mcowen hit
him with a low blow left hook to the
body and then a left hook up top and
shut the lights out and he went fucking
flat backwards,
arms over the top of his head and I went
fuck.
And I put on my running shoes and I went
out running and I ran a couple miles and
I remember when I came back home I said,
I have never getting upset over some
fucking dude.
I don't even know losing ever again.
I'm just gonna enjoy the fights.
So like to this day,
like when I call fights,
unless it's like you fucking guys.
Luckily you're not doing it anymore,
but you when you fucking fight or
someone I care about,
it's hard,
you know,
because I'm trying not to be,
but when I'm watching,
if I watched like anderson and bisping,
I'm wanting to watch a fight,
I want to see what happens.
I don't have,
I don't have a dog in the race.
I want to see.
And if anderson knocks amount or bisbing
knocks him out,
you don't care.
I liked the performance.
I like watching a performance.
Yes.
It changed for me at that day.
I remember remind myself my brother was.
We went into fighting.
I thought john claude van damme was the
man.
I thought that shit was real.
He is.
And was.
He still is.
Yeah.
But for me it was his head.
Mine was.
Mine was magic johnson,
my brothers,
Michael Jordan.
When magic johnson got aids,
I started crying and my mom had to
explain to a young man both,
and guys like that don't just represent
a conor mcgregor,
doesn't just represent himself.
Conor mcgregor represents a couple of
things.
One is possibility like self belief and
the idea,
the gall to say that I'm going to be a
champion coming out of nowhere and do
it,
but also like you have to look at where
he like Ireland.
They did a really interesting thing
about this during the financial crisis.
LIke what the greeks and people taking
to the streets and you know,
freaking out.
The irish are quiet,
suffers.
The irish are very stoic people.
They don't show off.
they don't make a big deal about their
own issues and pain.
IT's very an irish.
You get a guy like conor mcgregor all of
a sudden to come and they've had the
shit end of the stick for a lot of their
history.
And so when you get a guy like conor
mcgregor to come along and go,
hey,
by the way,
I'm going to beat everybody and I'm
fucking irish.
Who else did I help?
So I'm taking over for the for the first
time in a long time,
the irish like not holy fuck this guy
speaking for us.
And by the way,
unifying us that that's a big.
Historically,
he's actually,
in a lot of ways,
I'm probably gonna get shipped for this.
He's historically significant to the
irish and the irish character.
You're not that at all.
I think you're entirely right.
It's true.
I agree.
There's a reason it's so loud and stuff
because he is.
He's,
he's,
he's the guy who said,
hey,
it's our turn and who says we haVe to be
quiet and
keep our heads down?
Shit.
That's the real estate agents about god.
Damn.
When I went to Ireland a fight,
and this was connors.
What?
Second third fight in the ufc.
I think it was second he eating.
People knew who he was.
They obviously,
they had the show.
He's headlining.
I get there.
Wander around getting a cab.
Oh.
Oh,
you're fighting.
Okay.
Oh yeah,
here for connor,
like,
Uh,
sure.
Yeah.
I'm FuCking here for connor fighting.
I'm like,
okay,
wait for it.
And finding an englishman.
Fuck him.
Hope we die.
I'm fucking.
What's her name?
Ian mccall.
Oh,
you're a good irish boy.
Am I?
I'm not sure.
Okay.
They thought I was a fucking leprechaun
or something and this was.
This was just before he was a big,
big thing.
they were already fucking behind him so
much and now he is who he is.
Like you Said he
is.
He is changing the game completely.
Second fight in the ufc I believe was in
boston.
I think it was the second fight and was
the second fight.
Max holloway,
which was the second fight.
None of that.
The first fight was the first one was
berman.
Whatever the fight was that I called.
I don't believe I called his first
fight.
I think I called the second time,
but I remember being there going,
this is nuts,
man.
This guy is on the undercard.
He's on the undercard loud and they're
going fucking crazy and I think it's
because also boston is a giant irish
community.
Right.
But there was just something about this
guy.
I was like,
this is nuts.
Like the momentum had already started,
like way more than anybody I'd ever seen
fighting on the undercard.
But another thing that's going on with
connor is that everybody knows the
stakes are much higher because of the
shit talking.
He does see all this shit.
Talking is fantastic when you pull it
off,
but everybody knows that if he doesn't
pull it off,
if nate fucking sleeps him.
If nate connects with a straight left
right hook and we see the fucking
chicken,
you,
but you better stay offline for a couple
of weeks.
Oh my gosh.
What?
I mean,
he's got to,
aren't close anymore.
You don't talk to her,
but I couldn't imagine which is what I
saw when I was online.
the barrage of hate got hate for rhonda,
for telling people she was great for
expressing my,
my uh,
being impressed with her performance is
the amount of hate.
She got different wave.
Just a fucking.
But it might be different though because
rhonda was such a,
she was not a very gracious winner,
you know,
if you look at her,
which is climbing rocks and that
competition in the ultimate fighter and
she's given me the finger.
It was so aggressive and then did not
shake her hand and then to say what she
said about holly,
about being a fake ass preacher's
daughter and stuff.
That kind of stuff wasn't windy.
It was just,
it was just a lot of venom.
It's very hurtful
because then you're.
Then you're being a bully or being
exonerated.
Bull exists.
Fear,
you know,
people know that when she was doing that
with holly,
there was a fear and she was trying to
put that fear in the holly and the worst
thing in the world is holly just
standing out there,
dead,
faced drinking her water and she didn't
even their postage and all that.
That's cute.
ThIs judo is gonna.
Try and strike with me in the face,
bitch.
I like to use the word judoka.
Here's a question.
You guys.
Who are fighters?
Who or what about this idea?
What if,
what if meisha tate crawled on about a
three point stance.
Literally crawled toward holly home
because she couldn't get kicks.
John jones style right,
and just grabbed her ankle,
picked a single.
She won't be going to punch her.
she isn't a punch in the face.
Kick her arms,
but god,
that's not a viable.
Let's down kick the shit out of those
arms.
Let me tell you something to do,
to have you on all forms,
on all fours,
and someone kicks your arms.
That is horrific.
Great.
And your dumb ass to get up and fight
with one guy.
Sorry.
I just might.
My staff strategy.
Any other.
Hold on.
She's probably listening me.
Shit.
Don't do that.
It's climbed on top of the octagon and
leapt to the center of the roof.
Misha has a knife.
Guys.
You ever thought about that?
You can't do that if nisha knows named
jitsu golf.
Sleeping dust.
Yeah.
It's,
it's,
there's not a whole lot of things that
haven't been tried.
Hey,
what if meesha,
one and Conor got knocked down like 15
seconds.
Whoa.
Does dana shed a tear?
No.
Just keep on trucking.
Fuck you.
Keep on trucking.
Connor.
Still fucking welterweights or the
featherweight champion?
Not the same.
Your shit crazy if you think.
No,
no.
Not the same.
But look this.
The irish people are still going to
support him 100 percent.
Finding a job.
It's not the same as god.
He can win a rematch.
He's lost before he lost the Joe Duffy.
Not in the ufc.
We've never seen any loss to a 25 or he
does that little russian guy who leg
locked in with 20 minutes of them.
Really?
That's you're livinG in the past though.
I'm talking now.
These are just mega superstar.
He said 25.
Oh really?
Wow.
Yeah,
it was a long time ago.
Long time.
Doesn't matter that they're talking
about $25.
They could submit me,
you know,
get a hold of my shit.
Shit tat holding my legs.
See if you tap,
you know,
it's,
there's guys that Like it doesn't matter
if they get you in certain positions or
certain positions that some guys have.
They catching it like ronnie yahya.
Oh man.
That Guy has a whole year.
He's a tiny little dude.
He's also ultimate dad bod guy.
Tiny little dude.
First steve gets in,
gets a Hold of your team constrictor,
you know,
that's what they call themselves.
That is an app name because at that
motherfucker gets a hold of your neck
man.
You got some fucking problems live,
paula.
Yeah.
Well,
you know paul was versus gary tonin and
that submission only match at polaris in
that motherfucker.
Yeah,
he's crazy.
He's getting paid well for that.
every tone in his favorite in that
business carry tone.
That guy beat everybody at the eddie
bravo.
He's the favorite favorite there and
he's going to wrestle with pahara.
Don't say russell.
I mean he's kind of grapple with
submission,
grappling,
match.
I don't know if they have a weight
limitation,
which could be a giant issue because
paul rs gets way up into the two
hundreds before he fought.
He fought at one 85 his first fight in
ufc testing.
What's going?
Make sure that what you mean.
You don't have time for that bullshit.
Time for testing.
They want you to be on stage.
I want to quit everything.
I want to do steroids and I want to do
jujitsu all day and well,
how about fifth least diverse of all
these tourists take up class?
No.
Just get on steroids and start entering
competitions.
I'm going to do and then lose.
I'm going to lose gracefully at the
audit thing.
Just jump on the map.
We got to supermatch fucking loose
genres.
They come off in the middle of rolling.
Exactly.
Gosh guys,
you're hogs.
Fucking wipe it all.
The mess that happened to combine guy.
We talked a little bit of it.
Came out.
Know the combine,
right?
Cannonball tights.
yeah.
Giant Black guy.
run the 40 fat ass pterodactyl dick
comes out the front.
Even fucking falls in each shit on the
turf.
It was set and look at this girl who was
very excited.
It got a piece on The money when they
blurted out how dear you out.
You've got to find the real deal out
there.
Young james.
We got on the floor duty.
It looks like a pterodactyl going down
for prey.
It's all blocked off.
No,
no,
no.
It's like this weird fish consciousness.
Spirit out of the ground now.
Fuck that.
It's like on drastic park where the
teradeks are taken care of.
Here go fullscreen,
son.
Let's see.
Let's get this in our face.
Six five comes out right here.
He's all.
He's like,
no.
Oh shit.
My shit.
That turf dick.
because he scraped that chocolate dick
on that turf.
You'll see they let them do it again.
I hope so.
He's.
Oh yes.
I'm chris jones back in the heat.
You know how many instagram fucking
pussy pictures he must've gotten.
Oh,
you know what I mean?
Girls just sent his photos,
slid into his face down and also,
oh,
you're that guy to make this happen.
You're the dick turf guy.
Let's make this happen.
Dick turf guy went before you run that
comment,
like,
what's the worst that can happen?
I don't know.
IT's not like you're going to come out
or anything.
Just point here.
Volume of caulk when he was getting up,
but you see the mass.
Yeah.
Can you imagine how.
I don't know if you guys were at turf.
Burn on your dick.
Are you kidding me?
Heard a turf toe but choose to fall dick
first.
like that role though.
I definitely think he fell forward to
cover his dick.
Probably he knew.
If it came out of a short,
it was going to the ground.
Just let everybody see His dick.
If I had a dick like that,
I be fucking ripped my pants every day.
I'd be fine.
He falls down,
he gets up and tells the coach.
He goes,
my dick fell out like,
oh shit.
I just watched the get up freeze frame
on this table.
We went to right to count.
Fuck.
That's the problem.
That dude needs one of them diamond cups
just to contain that.
I don't see a problem with it.
There's no fucking sleeping.
Tells the coach goes,
damn my dick for title what that's
doing.
That's just reinforcing stereotypes.
I wasn't surprised.
I wasn't like,
oh my god.
It's trying to dig into it.
Yeah,
that's about right.
I didn't miss a beat.
I was like,
oh,
that's cool.
That's one of those stereotypes that
people don't have a problem with.
If that was a white guy,
I'm like,
oh shit.
I would have jumped out of my fucking
seat.
Like showtime.
Kick someone off the cage.
Yeah.
Polish guy,
fat white dick blythe,
snort and smoke dragon in this past big,
fat pale.
Makes me laugh right now.
Listen to the shogun.
I thought it was a breakdown and the
talking about dick.
I'm talking about it.
You know,
that's how grace has got.
What's really funny.
It people get angry at this podcast to
get angry,
get angry at some of the shit that we
say like what?
What?
What do you say when you're wIth your
friends and you're drinking,
what do you say?
Ninety percent of the time people get so
angry 5,000
thing because he got so angry that I
mentioned fried chicken.
Don't be mad at us.
Be mad.
He died fighting mma.
Here's the thing that's crazy that they
were upset at me that I mentioned fried
chicken because they said it was racist,
but they weren't upset that we're making
fun of a guy who is still in the
hospital.
Like this is how crazy people's
priorities are.
That first of all,
fried chicken is not racist.
It's.
It is a great food.
It's delicious.
It's fatty for you is not necessarily
the best food for you,
but that's not racist.
What racist is is claiming or or
pretending that one race is superior to
another race.
Genetically that's not what fried
chicken is.
Fried chicken.
It's just food and it was an example of
a bad diet was overweight and cutting
all this weight and look like shit.
How many people that are looking forward
to being angry so quick,
they need a reason.
Just looking forward to being upset that
like if somebody said if I was fat and
someone's saying you,
you meet,
eat motherfucker.
I'd be like,
yeah,
I like meat balls.
Like what is that so bad?
Because I'm italian girl.
You're genuinely not race.
I remember at one time I actually
remember asking you this so interesting
because you came from boston and kind of
working class kind of rough and I never
heard and I'd known you for probably
three years.
This is way back and I remember I said
I'd never heard you say you say bad
things about people you're fucking
meaning he's a ball hate,
but I have never heard that.
I heard you say anything off color.
Not once.
I never heard you say a prejudice thing
in any way and I remember
saying to you,
I go,
you know you never,
I've never heard you make an off color
joke about any race,
black people,
anything else,
and you said it never made any sense to
me.
He said,
You said,
you said,
I can show you a whole lot of really
dumb white people.
I grew up.
It's all about socialization.
I don't know if you remember that.
It just made.
It just makes.
It never made sense.
It's cold.
She gets obvious though with data.
If data was white and you went,
ah,
fucking fried chicken,
pepsi drinking,
no one's gonna say shit,
this is it.
This is how I feel about the data thing.
What I do feel bad about is that the guy
is still in the hospital.
That sucks.
Don't want anything bad to happen to
them.
I don't want anything bad to happen to
him.
I'm glad he's okay and genuinely all we
were doing was Joking around and having
fun because that's what we do and if
people construe that as racism,
because I mentioned chicken,
please substituted for pizza.
That's what I meant.
My intent is what's important.
People like you were trying to be funny,
but same fried chicken.
Yes,
I was.
but I don't think that's racist.
I don't,
I just,
it's food.
But it's funny that whole situation
when,
uh,
you know how when you do some crazy and
people we'll put.
Did you die?
Would,
yeah.
The hitch data dive.
Donna died.
Well he was his heart stopped.
Is that what happened?
Yeah.
Here's the thing,
man in everyone's saying,
you know,
that we shouldn't have been making fun
of his weight and his family was saying
that he was only two or three pounds
over the week of the fight.
Well then there's even less excuses
because if you're that much,
if you're only two or three pounds,
you're only cutting two or three pounds.
He's just unprepared.
So whoever did it,
they were upset at us that we were
making fun of his mma training or
strength and conditioning coach.
But this is based on perFormance.
We have to.
This is a coal main event and there's
something bigger at stake.
Like all due respect to data.
This is my feelings on the data thing.
Here's the good thing,
here's a compliment that I will give
him,
that god never quit.
His fucking heart had to give out and
that guy never quit.
He didn't have any insurance,
but he still fought three fucking hard
rounds and he had nothing in the tank,
but he never quit.
Is a loT of opportunities for him to
stay down.
He never quit.
He showed a lot of heart.
He wasn't like the way you think joe,
but he wasn't trained properly.
He wasn't prepared properly.
Don't have the skillset.
It wasn't ready.
No,
that's right.
And if you walk into that magnitude of a
fight and he have titties hanging,
I'm going to make a comment.
I make a comment like that about Roy Roy
Nelson to all the time you get to do.
What about Roy Nelson all the time.
And I've always said that roy nelson's
gut is like he's wearing like 30
sweaters and that it's just,
it's all like you're hitting
cheeseburgers.
You not even hitting him.
You're hitting all this shit.
There's,
but you know,
that's okay because I'm white and roy's
white,
but the those fights are not good for
the support and this is why they're not
good for the sport.
You're takIng two guys that look bad.
Their endurance and conditioning was
terrible that this.
The scrambles were awful.
Like when one time kimbo took him down
And just got on top of them and they're
just laying on the amateur.
It's just so.
It's so bush leagues that there's no way
that anybody who watches that,
like say if you're a boxing fan and you
watch like,
do you see karen's crawford the other
night?
That mother,
good luck beating that dude.
Damn,
he's good.
He murked that he's so good and you know
what man has switched.
He,
he'll fight You better.
Which southpaw.
I mean it's like marvin hagler almost
like that level of switch.
HiS ability to fight from either stands
just needs a big title like a mainstream
fight back.
If you're a boxing fan and you watch
that fight and then you say,
well,
let me check out what this mma shit's
all about,
and then you go and watch the kimbo dada
fight.
Just throw up,
throw up like this is an embarrassment
to the sport and this is not a mark
against them as human beings.
This is just where they are now.
Everybody starts off.
look,
if the first day you enter into any sort
of an mma gym or dojo,
whatever you all,
we all start out as someone who doesn't
know anything.
We all start out with whatever strength
and conditioning you've gotten coming
in.
You know,
if you're a gymnast or whatever,
you know,
you bring whatever base you have,
but we all start out not knowing
anything.
Once you get to a co main event,
I demand that you are better than that
tip.
It's that simple.
I demand it.
I agree amanda,
especially,
especially 2016.
fuck you man.
This is where I respect the shit out of
the ufc and dana,
when kimbo wanted to fight in the ufc,
they were like fight in the ultimate
fighter.
Like you want it,
you want to figHt in the ufc.
I know you're making a lot of money and
elite,
sexy,
and you know everybody's making it out
that you're the biggest thing.
But look,
When seth petros,
ellie,
fuck kimbo.
I know there's a video of me saying it.
I was watching it from the fucking green
room of the atlanta atlanta punchline
and I'd just gotten off stage and ken
shamrock got injured when he was
supposed to be fighting kimbo and I went
backstage and I saw seth petrosian.
I go,
what the fuck is going on?
And they said,
ken shamrock got injured.
I went,
no way.
And he said,
seth petrocelli stepped in the day of
the fight and took the fight.
I'm like,
oh no.
Kimball's going against the fucked up.
That's the first thing.
I never make calls like that,
but I said it.
It's on video.
You could watch the video of me saying
he's going to get fucked up.
And then he gets knocked out while we're
watching the video.
Like six seconds later.
I'm like,
I told you because there's a difference
between fighting guys who were awkward
and clumsy and you're a big tough guy
with good boxing and backyard and
fighting a mother fucker like seth
petrosa.
Let me ask you this,
joe.
How do you justify cm punk?
I Don't ask them to go on the ultimate
fighter.
From what I've heard,
they asked him and he was like,
first of all,
sweat that glorious bam suddenly get
that.
Why don't you bring that shit?
There's a last minute replacement sap,
which is always going to fuck them up if
I'm wrong and never see this,
so this is.
ThIs is the fight live.
Here we go,
oh my god,
why is it
right now?
But I had to be that high to give that,
that,
that breakdown,
breakdown,
get heightened.
That beer,
if you in my discipline kimbo this
through this is this is reality.
There's levels to fighting and this is
what I mean.
I'm an.
I'm an mma analyst,
is what do I do as a profession?
I've been doing it for a long fucking
time.
I've called thousands of fights.
That fight should not be a co main event
fight.
I'm not saying those guys shouldn't be
allowed to compete against each other.
They certainly should,
but they're not.
I mean I understand they want to get
paid and I get all that and I know the
kimball has some serious knee problems,
so I kimbo when he was on the ultimate
fighter,
they diagnosed him with bone on bone.
Cartilage.
Cartilage is just devastated.
his knees,
his needs are fucked from years of
football and you know,
all the mma training that he has done.
So I'm not hurt.
I'm not hating on those guys to get
paid,
but what I am saying is please bella
tour.
Cut the shit.
You can't do that.
The circus chance.
A real chance.
Beltour has a real chance of being a
gigantic organization.
They just signed benson henderson.
They got josh thompson.
They might get your boy mitrione.
They might get a bunch oF other really
good fighters.
They got vendor still but just fucking
signed with them.
They have a real chance at being right
up there with the ufc there a fucking
viacom entity.
They have a tremendous amount of money
behind them.
They're oN television.
They're on spike tv to it.
Right.
You know what's tough though,
if we're going to look at the rating
son,
over 2 million views.
Toys.is
titties or to the side and kimbro's gas.
It's hoists.
Gracie though.
That's what quite see.
I disagree.
I think it's kimbo was a huge draw.
What is your.
What if they didn't get toys?
You might be right.
What if they have the numbers in the
fight pass for ufc pushing.
Fight pass.
Put the freak shows on fight pass.
Yeah,
But why put kim on bypass when you get 2
million views on spike tv?
Maybe it'll drive viewers to your.
Your content in sucH bad shape that the
fight itself almost kills him and not
damage.
Just just competing.
Almost kills them.
Because if you look at the damage that
he took,
nothing.
Almost nothing.
Look,
the combination that dropped him like
the people have played it back and forth
like ghost punches his body failed.
If you ate the same shots [inaudible]
did against anderson silva.
Oh mY god,
you're dead.
Oh my god.
That fucking flying knee,
that fucking flying,
but here again,
if anybody felt that I said something
racist.
I'm sorry that you felt that way.
I really am.
I'm not sorry that I said chicken
because I think this is ridiculous.
It's a ridiculous argument and I think
in this day and age there's nothing
wrong with chicken.
Is nothing wrong with eating chicken.
It tastes great.
It's not racism.
Racism is trying to imply that one race
is inferior and that is just not
replaced chicken with any fast food,
fatty food.
When you're out of shape.
This is an example,
but there's a thing that people do,
man,
what they just looked to be offended or
they decide that this is somethiNg they
should be offended at.
Not looking at intent.
My intent was I'm talking about a guy
who obviously he didn't eat kale salads
and Fucking lean fish to Get to that
weight man.
Yeah.
That's another point is that when you.
When you say it feels like we live in a
time when,
when you.
When you are fighting for one group of
people,
like say people who have been oppressed
in the past,
instead of kind of having an intelligent
debate and pointing your guns where they
should be pointed out,
which is usually a complex set of
issues.
What we're doing.
I feel like as we're demonizing one
group to bolster another group that we
call not really.
They're not demonizing white people.
I don't think anybody's demonizing you
think people do.
I think.
I think a lot of times,
you know,
if you look at,
for example,
I,
I went to u penn and I spoke to these
kids in their theater department because
that's somebody asked.
Somebody asked me somebody,
somebody to do it.
It was fine.
Now they wanted me to do it about the
goldbergs and stuff and I was there.
I was there and I and I went and I asked
the kids.
I said,
how many of you feel like your comedy is
something you have to be careful of
because you might offend somebody in
your class or your school and half the
class raised their hands,
and by the way,
most of those kids,
because I did it,
I looked at it,
were mostly white and I thought that's a
shame.
That's such a bummer that your
expression and especially your comedy,
is being cowed by,
you know,
the fact that you're,
you're trying to be fair minded.
You know,
most of those kids,
I don't think we're racist or anything
else,
but when you're actually right,
but,
but we see this in our,
in our institutions of learning,
especially at a higher institution of
learning where you're just not able to
really an honestly express yourself and
god forbid,
it's funny,
god forbid it's a joke.
Uh,
you know,
if you're not,
if you're not towing the line,
then you will be censored.
Yeah.
I think it's a matter of demonizing
white people because it not demonizing
white people without doing that because
demonizing white people as demonizing,
looking for anything to be offended.
Right?
Even things that are not offensive,
right?
There's a lot of people took more like
chris rock took a lot of heat from other
black people.
I mean,
oh yeah,
white people and asian people.
So those were all very sensitive at a
time when we're making big strides as
well.
One hundred percent and I think part
of that,
the,
the over sensitivity is because we
sensed that there is a lot of positive
right?
And then people want to keep that going
and they want to stop any racism,
any racism that does come up,
they want to nip that shit in the bud
and let people know that it's not
tolerated anymore,
which is understandable,
but we have to know when it's.
When racism is real and when iT's not
real.
And there's also a lot of bandwagon
bullshit jumping on where people just
decide if this is something they should
be offended by,
where I'll sit down with you,
motherfucker.
You try to argue with me that that's
racist.
There's no argument.
Doesn't make any sense.
Mom who they just wanted to jump on it.
It's a stupid argument.
It's like watermelon watermelon's a
stupid argument.
Watermelons,
god damn delicious fruit.
You tell me the watermelon is racist.
You're an idiot if you're telling me
grape juice.
Watermelon,
chickens,
racist.
They're.
They're reacting though too to in the
past.
They're using what was used in the past
to create good,
but fried chicken has always been a
delicious food.
There's no time.
It's not like something that like poor
people could only afford and matter of
fact,
when who was it?
Who was running for president?
I think it was roosevelt when he was in
his campaign,
one a part of his campaign was a chicken
in every pot and the reason why is
because chicken was expensive back then,
so he was saying that he was going to
offer prosperity to the american people
and that every family would have a
chicken.
I'm offended.
Fried chicken's racist now just fended.
It's just,
it's not racist.
It's racial in that it's always been in
some way connected with black people,
but it's also not something only black
people eat.
It's not like curry when magic johnson
is like,
that's like a serious ethnic for say
someone smells like curry,
like that's more racial.
If you're talking about a racist person,
an indian person,
when magic johnson owned all his
starbucks,
he opened starbucks in black
neighborhoods and one of the first
things he said is,
you guys are selling food that black
people that I grew up with are not going
to eat and here are the foods you should
sell at my starbucks and he made a lot
of money by changing at what what they
were willing to offer.
What dId they change it to?
What was the new,
believe it or not,
I think one of the things,
this is back when I read about it for a
long time,
10 years ago,
more than that,
they were offering in the starbucks in
harlem and places like that.
They were offering things like sweet
potato pie because chicken not I don't
know,
but I noticed when I know pies,
magic mop god damn delicious.
Starbucks.
I'd never seen it.
That starbucks jet.
Imagine john said,
you got to this.
The food that you have in these is not
gonna fly.
Hold up.
Magic johnson.
Potato pie.
We don't make scones.
Scones,
racist.
That's cultural.
That's a cultural thing.
We know.
It's hilarious.
Another thing that people were trying to
get upset at me was orange soda.
Guess what?
Soda is not connected to black people.
It is just not.
It's not like saying that orange sodas
racist so that like the cover of yahoo,
they cut out cheeseburgers and they
wrote.
Joe rogan says that data ate fried
chicken and orange soda,
like they didn't even cheeseburger
because I was trying to throw in a bunch
of different things,
but orange soda is not racist at all.
It's a syrupy,
super sweet,
fatty drank soda.
It's very tasty.
It's thicker than a snickers man.
I love orange soda.
Sugar.
Addicted to those.
God damn delicious.
I'm a mangoes with chili.
Fuck me.
Fuck you.
And I just go in there.
They put a name on them,
bags of them.
I can't eat them.
This diet that I'm on,
you know what I should try.
I got a bunch of different companies
that I have back.
There you go.
Grab one.
Here's there's bags of them back there.
The one extra bagman.
They're the best ones.
The best ones that I've tried so far.
Trader joe's,
uh,
to the right,
the trader joe's ones are god damn
delicious.
Sugar man.
Me and sugar.
I don't everybody in sugar.
People were mad at me for talking too
much about sugar.
So I'm gonna shut the fuck up because
people aren't doing anything and do
anything.
Can't do anything.
Well,
you know what the deals were dealing
with volume.
The numbers.
I mean we've got like 23 million
downloads this month.
The numbers are insane.
Whenever you stand for something or
whenever you have an opinion,
chili,
mango.
Me too.
Whenever you stand for something or you
have an opinion,
people aren't going to agree with
everything man.
But,
but if people are disagreeing with you,
you're a schmuck mcmahon.
Well you're not.
You're not expressing yourself.
honestly.
You're not being original.
You're trying to please the crowd.
everybody has different points of view
and a few have nothing wrong with that
though.
You're not a hater.
You sometimes look at that.
He gave it to you all.
Thanks bro.
He's eating.
He's eating a fucking bar.
He's eating something super healthy,
low sugar,
and he handed that bag over the years
because I'm mexican doesn't mean that
like fruit fucking salt on it.
I never been able to figure it out.
Well,
it's the.
It's the chili powder man.
That's a delicious combination.
I had a dream last night.
I had a dream last night that I was
eating bread and that sand that someone
called me out on it and someone was
like,
dude,
you're eating bread.
I was like,
oh,
no doubt center got too high and I ate
the bread.
I'm not crazy.
What kind of a fucked up dream is that?
I'm eating bread.
THat was a real dream that I had.
I can't believe you're gonna run with
this diet for more than 60 days.
I'm definitely going to run with for
more than 60 days.
I felt great.
I'm down.
I don't know how much I'm down for this
morning.
And you start actually won 93 point
eight.
You started at two.
Oh,
two,
two or three bad.
Somewhere around like nine pounds down.
It's pretty cool.
And you're eating.
I'm eating like a pig.
My thing is when I'm at home,
but when remember whenever count I go on
the road or anything like that,
my diet goes to shit.
If I Had to walk around with a 10 pound
jacket on,
I would be an uncomfortable.
I'd be like,
get this fucking stupid jacket off.
I think that's how you have to look at
your body.
if you're one of those people that goes,
oh,
I could lose 20 pounds of who gives a
shit.
If you
take tHat 20 pounds and put a 20 pound
jacket on,
how would you feel you?
You're just accustomed to feeling like
shit.
So that feeling like shit becomes your
new normal.
I'll eat six cadbury eggs.
I fucking was cadbury eggs,
but if you want to kidnap them,
put some cadbury eggs in a van and put
them in the back of the van and then
he'll just can't help it gladly with
that.
Like one of those fucking is trapped.
Coyotes.
Slam the door shut behind them.
Got you.
We're in a meeting.
We're in a meeting couple days ago with
fox all suits and so and had a bag of
red vines like,
shop.
You want one?
They threw me the bag.
I was like,
ah,
fuck goes.
Holy shit.
He ate all of them in front of.
Everyone's like,
well,
I turn my head to look out the window
and then I turned back and they were
gone.
I was like,
what'd you do?
Swallow them all.
Can you tell her it is a drug?
it really is.
It doesn't seem like a drug because it
doesn't get you high,
but if there's a physical reaction that
your body has to sugar.
where when I would eat out,
eat a full meal and then after the meal
I would still be hungry for something
and what I was craving was either carbs
or I was craving cookies.
Like I see like a bag of cookies and
cookies,
sweet tooth sugar.
Meanwhile I'm stuffed.
Stuffed like I ate a giant meal.
Yeah.
I don't have a sweet tooth,
sweet teeth.
It's just like that all the time.
You know what I'm saying?
Because there's never ever not want
shogun.
Yeah.
But if you stopped eating it,
if you like took time off,
I guarantee you your gut bacteria would
change and that that craving would go
away.
Like I could look,
I could eat that.
No one's stopping me.
I don't have a like a law.
It's not like I'm on probation.
I can't have fucking sugar.
I don't want it.
What am I not?
Is raw honey different in your body?
No,
not really.
I mean sugar,
sugar.
But it's not terrible for you.
Look,
it's not terrible for you if you don't
get too much of it.
The problem is you're only really
supposed to have about 25 grams of sugar
a day if you live a healthy diet.
That's why I'm saying I'm saying good
luck in 25 grand.
So I do I think,
right?
Or do I do count?
You count.
But I think bread breaks down as glucose
quit.
No.
Bread is sugar.
Sugar and in pasta,
pasta,
sugar.
You know,
this diet,
this prime mark sisson,
the primal blueprint diet is no grains
and I've never done that before.
I've done gluten free before.
What had like rice noodles and stuff
like that.
This is the first time I've ever had no
grains at all and I just did it for a
goof,
you know,
I'm not doing it to prepare for it,
but listen to this guy,
mark sisson who was a very smart guy and
very interesting guy to talk to.
He's not,
you know,
he's not a bullshit artist and I'm
listening to what he had to say about
inflammation and all the issues that he
had dealt with.
Like acid reflux or what was it?
I listened to the show ids and also
joint pain arthritis.
I'm you.
That is the interesting thing.
I think I talked about this before the
podcast,
but when I get out of bed I don't have
any aches and pains anymore.
I would get out a bit that'd be like,
oh my fucking back and I'd have to
loosen up and I would do all these
exercises and shit before my body
started feeling loose again.
Like I'd have to like get my back move
and I'd get blood circulation and then
once they started circulating the aix
would kind of slowly go away.
I don't have any aches.
I get up,
I have nothing.
I just get up and it took me a while to
realize that go,
oh,
it's gone.
Have you ever tried fasting before?
No,
but I do intermittent fasting so I eat
at 9:00
at night.
Right.
And then I don't do anything until my
workout.
My workout is like 10:00
in the morning and then I workout and
then I eat after my workout.
So was for 11 hours or 12 hours or so.
I'm not eating shit.
See?
All on sundays.
I usually fast.
I stopped being saturday night,
usually seven.
I won't eat until the next day to seven,
24 hours.
That's,
you know,
if you have a good meal at 9:00,
you finished somewhere around 10 and
then you let all that shit digest and
then take that time off.
And then when you wake up,
like at nine or 10,
do a hard cardio workout,
it kicks in your body's desire to burn
fat.
You can also get away with eating some
sugar.
I worked out damn near seven days a
week,
you know what I'm saying?
So you'll burn a lot of that off.
Do you know?
It definitely will.
I mean,
you're not fat.
You know what
the geneticists things,
you know what epigenetics needed that
like a waiver.
So that was the final side.
Obviously a very a fit
guy,
you know what I mean?
You don't have any issues as far as like
your,
your appearance,
but as far as the overall performance of
your body,
if you just wanted to give her a goof
for,
for your show,
you know,
just to guide people through it for fun.
You know,
and I know a lot.
I've gotten all these tweets and
facebook messages from all these people
that are trying to do it now.
I want to do some outlandish though,
like an old cabbage diet for a month or
something.
But that's not unhealthy.
What you should do is just try it.
Try no sugar.
I know.
Look man,
I'm telling you.
I bought 10 bags.
Those fucking chili mango things back
there in boxes,
those sugary bars,
because I love him,
you know,
but I don't like them right now.
Like that doesn't have any pull to me.
That's what's the most fascinating thing
about this bread killed your coding.
Oh yeah.
I went to dinner the other day and we're
is tying restaurant with my family and
bread comes out and didn't mean shit to
me.
Do you know what they find?
Is that this?
From what I've read and heard,
epigeneticists got people who study how
you can turn genes on and off.
Right?
So that's a new science.
Do you know what one of the leading
causes of inflammation is?
Which I thought was fascinating.
Your gums and the food that gets stuck
in the middle between your gums will
break down as bacteria and apparently it
goes into the bloodstream and they're
finding that that has a.
First of all,
they know that that kind of bacteria,
it has a lot
to do with your heart,
heart health,
but it also has a great deal to do with
inflammation in the body,
which is a fascinating.
So that's why they say one of the most
important things you can do is floss.
Fuck that noise.
I know,
but that's.
But that's what the floss floss floss I
do now.
That will help me to floss picks.
Now I let her the past week.
I do it twice a day,
a dozen times in my entire life on this
planet.
I never got in my lungs so bad.
I like to pick up my gum.
Did you like those things?
You know what?
I like those waterpiks.
That's the shit.
Those are the shit and get the stuff out
of because it does as you sleep at
breaks down and it goes into the
bloodstream and that bacteria apparently
has a great deal to do with them.
That's why it's good to have a little
gap tooth.
Get some gaps in your teeth.
Oh,
a couple of teeth out.
No,
you don't want that gap.
So I,
I used to have a thiNg for girls with
gap teeth.
I'm not mad that either kind a thing for
girls.
I dated one.
Yeah.
No.
And they were dated,
dated a michael strahan.
Yes.
And it's not,
you know,
I'm just,
she was fucking gorgeous.
But I think it's hard.
I think it's hot girls would have gapped
too.
I'm trying to think of the hottest girl
that,
uh,
she was a bell girl.
J.
J dot bryce.
Perfect example that the girl on my bad
and she saw she only girl I know with a
giant gap we were yesterday.
We were talking about.
I understand it.
She's pretty good on the planet.
She's also one of the hottest people on
tooth or not.
Yeah,
there you go.
And you have to.
Yeah.
There's a lot of pretty women with gavin
to lauren hutton.
Remember that old school model?
Movie star,
apple gap tooth.
She was the poster girl when I was a
kid.
I remember seeing her,
but there's some new girl now I see,
I see on billboards with just a fucking.
Uh huh.
Interesting.
Yeah.
It was injured.
There's lauren hutton.
God damn.
You know what,
that's too much gap.
Nope,
not that show.
Back when she was hot and young.
I don't want to see some old girl and
she's.
She looks like fucking willy wonka.
Where's the gap tooth?
There it is.
Bam.
So my girl right there.
Look at that gap too.
That's a nice gap.
She's lucky.
She has them eyes.
She's beautiful.
She's good.
Do you guys pay attention to the
controversy?
Boy,
we're really breaking down these fights
and you guys pay attention to the
controversy that these models were
complaining about this oversized model
or plus size models.
As I said.
Oversized.
Sorry,
I'm oversized model.
I started again,
not my sports illustrated dude.
She's the hottest one.
Well they were saying these models,
these models were bitching.
Rhonda is saying that it's not healthy.
This is what she's doing is not healthy.
What?
Yeah,
because the bitch likes them and these
other girls don't eat what?
I just don't like skinny girls.
Only other skinny got to use it,
but I only weighed 125 pounds.
I know we can walk around at.
What's your walk around with 40 5:50.
Okay.
There she is in the middle.
In the middle eight for you.
Creepy.
Some giant tatami.
Yeah.
Let me see more of her.
Is there more of her?
Well,
she's the one by the way,
that is not wearing fucking body pain
that they might've put.
They might've put.
They might've been on rhonda.
You can't put body paint on them.
giant tathata.
You can't come late and cassie must
come.
Correct.
Pretty.
Jesus christ.
She's beautiful.
Come correct.
Alright.
Okay.
Now we got to slow down.
We to chill out because the legs and the
hips.
He meanwhile,
all this young lady needs to do is a
rigorous strength and conditioning
program for a couple of weeks and she
said,
oh,
okay.
Well we just got a little ridiculous
here.
Well,
is that her back?
Their faces.
Beautiful.
She fluctuate.
She's super hot body.
I liked it.
I see that they're riGht.
It's perfect.
That's perfect.
Is that her okay?
Right there.
It's perfect.
She fluctuates or maybe her midsection
looks like my mind.
I'm not mad.
Don't get me wroNg.
Out of those three girls,
she's.
Yeah,
I bet.
I bet she has no problem dealing with
the shop.
Like,
You know what I'm saying?
Like you,
you,
you can't like over fuck her.
She's ready.
Want a big man?
oh,
breads.
She's not like,
oh no,
no,
no.
You can't go hard to know that she,
she,
she's just gonna get you a full guard.
She is your god.
Do her face is beautiful.
She's gorgeous.
She's your.
There's a lot of variety in the photos
of her.
Like some of her wish she looks perfect
and some of her,
which she was obviously like a little,
you know it's going to be true.
How old is she?
What does she went?
Early twenties when she's 40.
I don't know if that's all.
There's no such thing as one of these
models that's in any,
any.
You know,
what do,
what does she weigh?
because she's 87.
Twenty nine.
Okay.
There's no such thing as these models.
When they're 40,
they don't exist.
Especially the plus size,
not the plus side one out.
They just don't exist.
They didn't.
Nobody wants to see it.
Cindy crawford's still doing the damn
phone she's been on,
but that thick,
just she's this good for you girl.
Love the man,
but cindy's,
that's a full time job.
She's on it all day with creams and and
I accident lotions and rubbing fucking
luke was all over her face and she's
rubbing sand over face,
smoothing it out and exhausted,
exhausted,
exhausted as a sand storm.
Hey,
I gotta run.
I going to go for a jog.
She probably sees like fat,
ugly chick.
She was like,
I wish.
Who is the,
um,
the girl who was in body heat.
Kathleen turner,
turner.
She was so moved and she got,
she became an alcoholic.
She beat him and jamie came like,
drank a balloon animal.
She drank a lot.
She got,
she became a.
She blew the fuck up.
Not only that,
she got that balloon,
that drunk face where something happens
to your nose,
your nose.
Look at where,
when she was upper left corner,
please look at that dude.
She was so hot when she was young.
That body heat movie,
that was night time.
We get her to bring her patients.
She's sniffing cock.
She had a real,
she had a real husky sex with this.
Mike smells like shit.
These things changed.
Can I take these off?
they don't come off your breathing.
Is this yours?
Just upset that I've been talking to
people.
This is what's been coming out of my
mouth.
I feel rude.
I was brushing the teeth this morning
with dark shit.
Yeah,
like she was crazy about this chick.
This is a really hot girlfriend.
Nineteen 81.
If you saw her at the gym today,
billy [inaudible] probably be here more
often.
I want to be a hell of an actress.
I want to see her.
I want to see her now.
Jamie.
Well,
the bodies that women have today are
just better because their athlete,
I mean better for what I like.
I like to like a gal who looks athletic.
Like that's what I like.
I like girls like crossfit girls.
Like look at her now.
She,
she did a lot of drinking that jesus
christ.
He did a lot of training,
a lot of drinking man and women are like
little fucking asshole.
What a real nah man.
She's 50 fucking years old.
You piece of shit.
That's a lot of booze.
Meanwhile,
cindy crawford is $50 to brinkley.
Yes.
Christie brinkley's 90,
9,150
years old.
We'd all fucking fucker after you guys
fucked her.
How about that?
I'm going to pretend that that's her.
When she was in that movie body heat,
great movie.
She let herself go.
Maybe she got money and says,
fuck you.
It's not a drink.
It's booze and cigarettes.
Because with that voice she smokes.
She had a serious drinking problem.
Did she stop?
I don't know,
but I know she's talks about it.
MayBe she had a blast.
Got some money.
Starts smoking.
Got fat as fuck.
And cadbury eggs.
I'm not mad at it.
It was just get tired of getting dick
and she's like,
I gotta keep the deq away exhausted.
Might be gay.
In fact,
I think.
What kind of why I'm saying just think
everybody's gaining.
Yeah,
I know her barrier to spread rumors.
So how do you do?
Can I do chi greens and venice a lot?
He's gonna.
It's gonna fuck you up.
Going to fuck.
Fuck you up.
I mean he's going to fuck you.
like he fucked that greatest straight
way.
Oh,
that's hilarious.
Yeah,
I just don't.
I mean I think also the pressure of
being a hot chick.
Cool.
Like it's so overwhelming.
I think after awhile they,
just from speaking from personal
experience,
my days as a hot chick,
I just think it's overwhelming for those
girls to imagine your entire existence
is based entirely on people wanting to
fuck.
You can find on symmetry and guys just
sending mental dick missiles at your
face all day long.
Dude.
I used to.
I used to work at this gym where I won't
say her name,
but that noise,
a very famous mental dick muscles is a
famous female celebrity would work out
there and she would go in the shower
before me,
but the pop routes he is waiting for
outside.
She was in there for damn near two hours
would come out and full makeup ready
because there's so much pressure because
people are just taking the time to bat
for him hard.
It's hard.
Zellweger said that she moved to New
York because when she'd get out to put
gas in her car,
if she brushed her nose,
they take a picture and it looked like
she was picking her notes.
She just was followed everywhere.
She was like,
I'm going to New York to live.
By the way,
for a girl like that.
Um,
whenever I'm around him,
I have to say,
by the way,
by the most,
that's contagious as fuck by for sure.
When I'm around him,
I say for sure when I'm around use by
the way,
it's just exhausting to be one of those
ladies does hot and she also had to get
a fuck load of plastic surgery.
I mean she didn't have to,
but she did try to keep up,
man.
It's a fucking dog race.
If you're a hot chick,
it's not good.
Not good.
It's rough.
You have an expiration date to pretty
much.
I mean that.
That's going away.
Yeah.
Patty jenkins,
you know our friend who's who directed
wonder woman now and she said,
if you want to be humiliated,
b of a woman,
a female actor in her late thirties,
early forties,
you know when,
when you start to lose quote unquote,
your delicious,
as katharine hepburn said,
you become invisible.
Oh,
you want three oscars?
Awesome.
We'll see atlanta.
THere really aren't any,
any parts for it.
It's tough.
Even anne hathaway thought about that.
She said she was the young girl getting
the parts and now she's not getting
them.
She's like,
I get it.
It's the business.
Nineteen year olds taking my job.
I used To be that 19 year old.
Yeah,
but here's the thing,
okay.
I can't get a job playing a black
basketball player because I'm not a
black basketball player.
You know what I'm saying?
I can't get a job plaYing jackie chan's
brother because I don't look like I'd be
jackie chan's brother.
If you want a job as a Hot chick,
you have to be too hot.
Chicks,
right?
When you are no longer a hot chick,
you're going to have to get a job as a
hot chicks mom.
Yeah.
That's not reality.
That's what.
What the fuck did you do to get famous
in the first place?
You've got the genetic lottery.
You're mad.
Genetic lottery has an expiration date
on my god.
I feel so bad.
It's so hard for women in this business.
It was pretty fucking easy for you to
slip in the door.
All you have to do is have good
features.
A hard for guys in this business.
THis business is ridiculous with the
businesses who want to be in.
In that extent.
It's who wants to fuck you?
Fuck you.
We're going to find someone a lot of
fuck.
I lost the part because my manager
called me because I'm going to be
honest.
They just said,
you weren't tv.
good looking enough.
I was like,
that makes seNse.
I agree with that.
That's reality.
It's not true.
What's not true?
Thanks to what they were trying to.
Well,
if they're trying to catch you as the 30
something single guy.
Yeah,
probably new like my age.
I'm lost with the plane crashed and you
were fairly rugged and you took care of
some older women and they wanted to fuck
you.
You're the guy.
Yes.
My buddy frank.
You know How to make a fire with my
buddy frank grillo.
The greatest guy will call me up.
He'd be like,
dude,
you got to get down on this audition and
I would call my h and m bitch and
finally my eights and david letterman
goes,
brian,
he just stopped me because brian,
you have to stop calling me about the
audition.
Frank grillo goes on and I said,
why?
He goes,
because you don't look like franklin,
his casting.
You could play his friend but you don't
have his hair.
His look and he just,
he got mad at me and I was like,
you know what?
You're absolutely right.
I don't know how it so goes and you
can't get upset at that because that's.
You got in just as easy.
You didn't get a goddamn phd to be a hot
chick.
You know?
It sounded like you fucking scoured the
world and and busted your ass 16 hours a
day,
going through doctorate your
dissertation and fucking writing books.
No pretty girl,
no cetera.
Pretend for you to be upset that people
don't care about you because you turned
40.
Well,
guess what?
You're in the wrong god damn business.
They're not going to care about you when
you're dead either and you're going to
die.
So there's a certain reality to the
expiration date of the occupation that
you've chosen because you've signed up
for sports too.
And this is not the fucking businesses
responsibility,
you know?
I mean,
I,
I was friends with the guy who's asian
who's always complaining about the lack
of asian roles in hollywood,
and I was like,
well,
okay,
but they don't have to write a movie
about asian people.
THey're like,
well,
he's like,
it's a close system.
Well,
okay,
you've got to figure out a way through
the system.
There's a certain way that has to be
available to someone to get a gig and
they shouldn't have to cast you just
because there's no asian people and
they're moving.
Well,
that's gone,
that's going on in hollywood for
example,
like the black issue in hollywood.
Look,
black people take up what 12 percent of
the population in this country.
There are a lot of very talented black
people as there are a lot of very
talented people,
but the bottom line is moneywise,
you know there's more money and making
sort of movies that are geared maybe
toward a white populace only because
that's the economics.
There are a whole lot more audience
members that are white and and the
infrastructure,
Yes is already fairly white,
so It's going to take some time,
but two to mandate or to kind of scold
hollywood because there aren't enough
vehicles or roles for black people or
asian people.
It seems to me to be a little bit
disingenuous.
I understand the frustration,
but come on man,
at the end of the day,
it's reflective of demographics,
isn't it?
Isn't it reflective of the fact that 12
percent of the population or are african
american?
Most of this country is still white and
it's still a business?
I think it's still a business on
addition.
A couple months ago when grain was
between me and one other guy and the
other guy was african american male
agent called me.
He goes,
man,
you did great.
You they think you're better,
but they're there.
They're gonna.
Go with the better.
Yeah,
they think you're better than to go with
african americans.
they want diversity because they don't
want to get people upset at.
First of all,
it's a fact.
first of all,
there's effective.
If it's effective,
you're casting a movie tv show.
Now it is a fact that,
and I,
I just know this,
that you have to cast a certain number
of people have quote unquote color that
is,
you don't have to.
You don't have to,
but if you want to avoid criticism,
and that's one of the reasons why this
criticism exists,
is criticism.
It's essentially like an affirmative
action for acting.
It says nfl too.
You know,
if you're hiring a head coach and then
you have to interview a black coach,
you have to.
It's required.
You have to interview a black coach,
so you might have six white guys and
you're like,
fuck,
the sixth one's really good.
I knOw,
but you've got to put in this inferior
black yet we have to do.
They're trying to do.
They're trying to equalize the playing
field and create equality of
opportunity,
which is a good thing.
I just don't know if that's the best way
to do it.
Well,
what is the best way to do it?
Best way to do it is to a meritocracy
and create opportunities for people of
all ilks and all colors earlier,
earlier,
nurture,
various cultures.
Nurture the Idea that,
hey,
instead of taking this path,
maybe there's another path.
I'd love to see more black.
For example,
let's just take black more black
scientists and doctors over more black
actors and things like that.
Yeah,
but know you just saying they want to do
the way you do it.
As you nurture those communities when
they're still young,
I'm undergoing possibilities.
Best guys should get the job.
I don't care.
It doesn't matter.
I think that's true too,
but I also think we've got to figure out
why those people aren't getting
opportunities.
Like what is it that is the question.
That's the same opportunities.
They're not born with the same
opportunity.
They were given a shitty deal as far as
the hand that you're dealt as at birth.
That's got to fix the haNd,
but also keep in mind when you.
First of all you're talking about black
people,
gay people,
whIte people.
It's so ridiculous with very different.
A black from black people and gay people
to get to a black person.
I'm in Nigeria is very different than a
black guy from who grew up in South
Carolina.
It's just a completelY different culture
and everything.
The black,
the african immigrant immigrant
experience in this country is not so
different from a lot of other immigrant
experiences.
Um,
so culture plays a factor in Where
people start and end as well.
We don't talk enough about that.
We don't.
It's very taboo to suggest maybe your
culture if you're a white guy from the
appalachian mountains,
isn't as effective for this marketplace
as the culture of a northeastern white
guy.
Maybe your culture if you come from a
black minister,
Mississippi black mississippians
neighborhood or or wherever data $5,000
from in that,
that documentary,
it's chicken,
but that coke
soda.
What are the deficits in that culture
compared to the deaf to the advantages
of being a black kenyon or a black
nigerian that seems to work in this
marketplace.
Let's start talking about that.
If you don't want to have a discussion
about that,
maybe you don't care.
I don't know what you just said,
so I can't really agree with what I'm
saying is that culture plays a factor
when you solved the problem is look at
how kids are raised.
Start with there.
Well,
I think for sure we have a problem in
this country where there's communities
where people are grown growing up,
where it's just despair,
despair and crime.
BaltiMore,
detroit,
me keep going down the list of terrible
communities where people are born that
no one's doing anything to try to fix.
The government,
looks at all these problems that are
having.
the people are having another other
countries and they're like,
we have to help these syrian refugees.
We have to help.
We help people in detroit too,
man.
You know how help people that are
hurting are,
but you're also dealing with a legacy of
raid.
That's where racism is a legacy.
Where black,
what black people were redlined.
Well,
I had this guy Michael Wood on who was a
cop,
how baltimore is a good one,
great fucking guy,
super articulate,
smart,
and he's actually running for mayor of
chicago or excuse me for the head of
police or chicago right now and well,
I hope he wins because he's got the
right idea and he was a cop and he's
fucking super honest guy,
but he said that the way baltimore was
set up,
you literally couldn't sell black
people.
How white called being redlined in every
community.
Why is there a black ghetto in almost
every community?
That's a bad part of town.
How?
What a coincidence.
It's black.
You couldn't get a loan for a house
unless it was in within these lines.
THat's how it was.
That was,
that's what you call institutionalized
racism and the people they didn't own
those houses they were renting and weird
is there's.
There's really no.
If you think about it,
just to go back to what we're supposed
to be talking about.
If you go back to it,
there's really no black female fighters.
Angela hill.
okay.
Who was mad at me by the way,
for at 1:35
percent fried chicken.
She sits,
she made a twitter post,
says this is what she hears,
and she had a a clip of me from my 2005
showtime special where I said there's
three magic words.
Love con in nigger.
Those are the three magic words.
And like in the last one,
you can't even say out loud,
not even calling.
Somebody can't say it out loud.
Say it out loud.
People could beat the fuck out of you
for sure.
I mean,
that was the point of the bit,
so she took an excerpt of that and she
said,
this is what I hear when he says that,
and she'll.
She was super upset.
Is the planning.
It is disappointing at 1:35.
There's not a lot of african americans
in the female division.
No,
there's no.
There's some,
but it's nice that for especially women,
but if you think about there's some
beast african american women.
It's a new sport.
Fucking monsters.
Wait until they get into it.
Wait til you have too little.
Serena williams sisters who maybe I
should fight.
See everybody fucking athletes.
So there's old lady.
Hey people,
black people her,
she's white,
but her kids are black or half and her
daughter looks like venus and serena,
she's 15 and he,
we should play tennis together.
Fuck you.
How fast,
how fast you serve.
She goes,
oh,
a little over $100.
Why the fuck would I want you serving a
ball at me and make a play tennis with
callan?
Callan is a fucking stopped.
When I hit takes,
he takes lessons.
You're the pro bodybuilder.
Gag.
I go back and I go,
it's a long one.
God never go surf.
I go,
eat,
eat my dick.
That's a good thing to say because
there's lots of flies right by you.
Say,
eat my dick.
Yeah,
but wait to with the african american
girls go,
you know what,
we can kind of make money in this fight
game.
Well,
you get the white girls are fun.
A lot of russian and a lot of pole like,
you know,
you,
you want to check and uh,
there's,
there's a lot of molly tie in europe and
in Russia and I think a lot of those
athletes are going to leak into mma and
muscle farm issue.
She's doing summer camp up muscle
thoughts.
Great.
I would also suggest that black being a
super whatever athlete as a black.
There's only one black champion right
now,
right?
You got luke rockhold johnson is the
current champion.
St John Jones.
Okay.
And then you've got really,
let's say John Jones,
then you got in the heavyweight
division,
it's a fabric to have our doom.
then you've got robbie lawler who's
filipino and white,
and then you've got at 4:55.
Does filipino and white.
Why did I not know that?
That's on?
Just then you got.
So it's mighty mouse and john jay.
Yeah.
Hoffeld this on joe's.
Well connor.
Yeah.
Mighty mouse and,
and,
and daniel's the to keep saying jon
jones.
Daniel cormier is the champ.
I apologize daniel.
kind of because I watched jon jones beat
the fuck,
but I didn't watch out of him,
but he didn't disagree.
He broke him.
He won.
He definitely won.
He broke them.
When is that fight happening?
April 23rd I think is already billboards
for it.
What'd you get?
What'd you call calling that?
Jon jones motivated and in shape.
Power lifting is a dangerous
motherfucker.
But how much of this is bs?
You know,
we don't,
we never faked.
So he's bigger,
stronger,
faster with time off,
and he already beat them before.
Well also,
um,
it seems like he's on the straight and
narrow and he's training all the time
posting to instagram.
Why?
I think it's,
I don't know,
because our lawsky this is the only
reason why I questioned at all or lawsky
said he's never in the gym for arlovski,
you know,
might not like who's this?
John's.
Yeah.
When did he say then?
Recently he might,
they might be coming at different times
or are laskey might've been quoted,
but it might've been an older quote,
you know,
he might've been,
talking about six months ago it was john
with no camp camp doesn't fucking matter
to this dudes beating people the fuck
up.
Well joHn and shape and motivated.
So,
you know,
it's interesting.
One of the things that he said that I
think was really honeSt and intense,
he said he used to always give himself
an excuse for losing.
So like if I lost,
I'd be like,
well I didn't even really train,
wait till I train.
And then.
But he kept winninG,
you know,
it was saying this,
this fight,
he's not doing that and this fight.
He is like in some serious shape.
The power lifting shit is no joke,
man.
When you're watching them do all that
power lifting heavy dead lifts,
I'm like 500 pounds,
whatever it is a lot,
but it's.
The point is his body has obviously
changed,
like he's been putting some serious work
in.
there's no doubt about it.
You can see the physical results in his
body.
He's biGger.
I just,
I don't.
And I love dc.
You know this dc.
I love them.
I have worked on the.
I just don't see dc having the skills to
beat him.
I don't see it happening.
What would dcf do differently?
Because you have to do something to
train with kane.
That's the big one.
Well,
peace out,
but cain is injured obviously.
Yeah,
but cain was a big part of his training
camp and cane like having cane as a
click on that fucking video of him
kicking.
Go to that one right there.
Let me see that.
Let me see.
This got jacked.
His.
He's in some serious shit.
I want to see his kicks because that's a
big part of his game,
man.
God,
doug.
I can help them with that move as from
foot first.
I'm going to talk to him,
but that's what you're supposed to do is
step out and then you can.
You don't have to.
You just wouldn't know.
You.
Turn your fucking front foot man.
Don't ever,
ever turn your shoulder.
Ever get me kicked out because I can see
you there.
You don't know what you're talking.
He uses it all the time.
You turned your front foot first.
It's the most imPortant part of you.
Keep your body exactly the same or you
pivot on that foot when you go up in
your heel and you can get a lot of
power.
Which showing how the kickoff.
I will 100 percent in 2016.
Please let me show you a kickoff.
You'll see.
We'll go in the back after the.
Oh,
he definitely could do this better,
but what's important is that you know
who's gonna I,
I,
I Just don't think we know at dc.
Brings that crazy relentless pace.
Boxing.
Wrestling.
Yeah.
What's he.
What's he?
Gonna do start kicking.
What's he gonna do different.
I'd love to hear it and I love dc,
but we don't know how much of all the
shit talking and the eMotions and all
that stuff played a factor in his
preparation and his execution During the
fight.
We don't know.
We won't know until we see them go at it
again.
We don't know how much of a factor cane
would play because canes not as camp
right now because ken got injured
training for for So he's not there
again.
Not and cain had fucking back surgery,
which is some serious shit.
He up for trunk of his disc removed or
dude.
Well,
it's also not necessarily necessary
because matt brown went through same
injury and matt brown didn't bother
getting surgery and cm punk won and got
surgery too and I have been through it
and I didn't get surgery,
but that's where I got that machine that
reverse hyper that's in the back.
All the yoga that I did all the other
different.
There's a bunch of different treatments
that you could do to take care of a
bulging disc and they involve
lengthening your body,
stretching and decompressing your spine.
And it heals it.
It can heal itself,
but is supposed to be faster,
right?
Yes.
But it's also permanent,
man.
He take away that chunk of disk,
that chunk of disc is gone now,
man.
It's gone.
What?
They replace it though,
correct.
Replacing a disectomy what cain went
through.
What he's got is a bulge,
right?
I'm not a doctor.
Just wants to that record.
So here's this,
here's this back.
Right.
So here's the spinal column.
And then he's got his discs right next
to it.
Well,
one of his bulging disk is pushing
against his spine,
dan.
Okay.
So spinal column,
like his spine,
she's actual spine.
That's where you get nerve pains.
But that's why.
That's why you have um,
a dyadic comes from.
And for me,
I had a,
I had at both places,
I had a little bit of a psychotic at one
point in time.
And then I had it in my fingers.
The fingers was real bad though,
but that was cervical.
Um,
when it happens,
they just go in there,
they open you up,
they cut that piece out and then go
back.
And so now it's not pressing up against
you,
but a chunk of your discount and you
know,
you,
you have less friction.
They're not necessarily either way that
mother fucker's not back for dc.
Exactly.
He's not going to be bad.
Not back for dc.
Matt brown fixed it and matt brown fixed
it with louie simmons.
Same guy who created that reverse hyper
west side barbell.
I mean he went through a bunch of
exercises and a bunch of different
things to fix it.
There's ways to fix it depending upon,
of course,
how bad the injury is with some people
it's herniated to the point where they
have to remove the disc tissue and
either put a spacer in there or the
fuse.
The two discs together.
Spacer is generally thought to be the
better move for athletics.
That's what I thought they did with
cane.
No,
no,
they,
they did a disectomy because they did a
space or he's out for a long time
because you just know there's no
wrestling going on for a long time.
For awhile though.
Correct?
Just a few months.
I just can't believe that that jon jones
took daniel down twice.
Twice.
Nothing.
Right.
I mean he took them down the first
thought that was possible.
Strong.
He is.
He's very good.
Frank meir said he's like wrestling with
jon jones.
Nobody realizes that.
Strong and sorted,
sorted a good assuming stronger.
NoW.
He's so crazy strong.
I don't know if it's leveraged,
but uh,
it's all the above is also a juco.
National champ.
He's a nightmare.
Cradle.
Ryan bader didn't cradle him.
Was,
it was a battery.
Did that too where he just put him in a
cradle and just the show run.
I mean,
he literally didn't watch it other way.
Rumbled did.
That was horrifying.
Yeah.
Rumbles.
terrifying.
He scared me more than I want to see
rumble fight.
Jon jones.
It's whether or not rumble can continue
that sort of.
You don't think jan's takes him down
deep into the second,
third floor.
People are going to figure it out.
They already have figured it out.
Yeah.
Daniel,
did you drag on the later,
right?
You avoid The big punch dragon in the
later rounds.
John's change.
Can a guy like him?
Can a guy like rumble change?
She's obviously changed and gotten way
better in the avoiding the weight cut.
Becoming a real natural two.
Oh,
five pounder.
Kenny change in far as like not being
able to be broken the way dc broke up
with josh koscheck.
Vito belfort,
broken.
I don't think you're born with it.
It's a part of your personality,
so whether whether or not you allow your
mind to go down,
those psychologists can probably help
you disagree.
Maybe.
Is iT possible?
I don't think so.
are there examples,
but the whole lot it's like,
ooh,
who's been broke?
But how can you say it's not possible
because it's mental.
If it's mental,
it's most certainly don't tHink it's a
personality trait.
It's not possible for me to win the high
jump.
I don't have it physically right now.
Let's say for him,
for him though,
it's.
It's a mind issue,
but why?
Why couldn't a man adjust the way he
looks at the world?
Isn't it possible that you could,
through a rigorous disciplined,
like very focused attempt to change the
way you approach various scenarios and
dilemmas?
Isn't it possible that you could change
your thinking and wouldn't that be more
likely that you could become more
mentally tough than it would be that
you'd be like this physical free because
it's a physical thing in cardio makes
brings out the weakness in people,
so what are you going to do?
You can put them through these crazy
cardio challenges and have a mental
coach there.
Now here's The point where usually
break.
Let's keep going.
Here's what I say.
First of all,
I don't know nearly enough grappling
before,
I think that was a big part of the issUe
was he was getting mad dogged by a guy
who was an olympic caliber wrestler and
daniel cormier was just ragging him all.
I know he did.
I bet he did.
Crazy.
No,
he didn't.
I know he didn't.
Now he's gotten near atlanta.
Who's a FuCking giant neon millennia.
Best fans in the world,
rapper might be the best deep,
deep knowledge of submissions,
but also a lot of catch.
He's really.
He's very knowledgeable about catch
wrestling and jujitsu also understands
big man jujitsu.
He's a big motherfucker and if you're
rolling with that guy,
guarantee you spending some time on your
back.
If randy couture's black belt,
he's randy couture's cop forever neoma
lance and he's a stud.
This is a fucking crazy.
No mylanta and ready for this nigga
lance and had a broken toe.
They said,
neil,
you're going to have to be off the mats
for six months.
He goes,
cut it off.
The ronnie lott.
Lots of that.
Yeah,
he had his toe cut off so he could keep
rolling.
Come on,
son.
I going to go into that terrible mental
fortitude ahead.
Going back to the mental thing with a
mental coach,
man.
I think sometimes there's just.
I don't know,
man.
I think some people,
it's just in their dna.
They just break easier now when she gets
a dna,
what I think
it is is it being a big,
strong,
tough guy and being used to being the
hammer and then when you're the nail you
can't handle it and you fall apart
because it's an n.
You're uncovering your unaccustomed to
it rather than a guy like,
here's a good example,
darren elkins,
you can hit that motherfucker with a
baseball bat and he keeps coming
forward.
He's used to getting beat on.
He's not a big guy.
He's a tough guy.
John jones isn't the only had him with
jon jones is a fairly trained,
was getting beat up.
John jones has two big brothers and his
bigger brother beat his ass all through
his life and I think he's accustomed to
getting his ass beat by his big brother.
I think his brother arthur didn't have a
fantastic service and being bigger and
kicking his ass for sure,
but I think it goes in two ways.
Either you're born with it,
like you said,
or some traumatic event in your life
that maybe it's has something to do with
it.
Maybe it doesn't,
but it switches on that quit and you're
in your in your mind and your body.
Some of it's just mental.
Some of it's physical.
Your body gives out or your brain gives
out.
I think there's multiple ways to look at
it.
Obviously vinny shoreman could fix him.
Finished romans a hitman chest.
Shout out tonight.
My mind coach vinny.
That's what he calls himself.
My approach.
It's.
I think it can definitely be a learned
behavior to to quit.
Whether it's you got taught that or you
got that imposed on you or someone made
you break when you.
It's a habit that there's just a little,
a lot of ways to go about it,
you know,
not saying something bad happened in his
life.
Maybe it was something good that made
him say,
well,
fuck this.
I'm out.
I don't think at his level he's gotten a
coach.
You don't think he's ever talked to
them.
There's a lot of fighters that have
never gotten a mental coach.
Like I asked cowboy about it and he's
like,
shit,
I can't put laughed in my face.
Well,
kevin has never had a fucking mental
coach.
Tazzy do you think cowboys at a mental
coach?
I don'T know why you're making that
face.
you think he's a liar?
No.
How dare you?
Ian,
what?
What do you when you're kind of one
against the ropes here.
Why don't you talk to yourself?
Like what do you do?
I'm my worst on my,
my own worst enemy,
so I just fucking talk shit to myself or
it depends.
Sometimes I'm going in,
I feel great and some days I just sit
there and I'm like,
wow,
I'm fucked.
Like going out for my last fight,
sitting there backstage and just slumped
in the chair.
Why?
I don't know.
This was after working with vinny
though?
No,
no,
no.
I started working with any after this
and you know,
a personal problems with me.
It's always like women problems.
She's in monday,
dear you little girl effect your.
Hey,
let me ask you this before.
It's not gonna,
it's gonna happen again.
I say this the same as any other job and
I'm sure with stand up some nights and I
felt this way,
there's probably three fights,
man.
Any other night I'm down.
I jUst don't Feel like fuCking fighting
tonight for whatever reason.
I just don't feel like it.
Well,
standup is way more relaxed.
I know.
I'm just saying for your job.
Yeah,
sure.
There's nights when you're performing
for the thousands of people,
you're like,
Damn,
I really don't feel like doing it.
It's usually the same thing.
It's usually a girl thing,
like you get in a fight with your
girlfriend or Something like that and
you go out there.
You just don't feel funny.
I fuck up when I have an acting job.
This is gonna sound crazy,
but sometimes when you have an audition,
I think about this and it's three pages.
It's just three pages.
You can do it in your sleep.
Guess what?
It's the.
It's the network tests.
You go in there.
There are probably 15 people show tell
you have to do is Just do three pages.
I've gotten myself.
There is between Me and another guy,
right.
If I get it,
I will make a million dollars.
I will make $1,000,000
for the year and I won't have to work
for it.
It's a sitcom.
I'll make a million dollars.
Just do what you did.
Just do three pages.
It's no big deal.
It's like,
don't miss that putt.
That's when I get nervous.
That's when I fucked myself.
See I went,
when I went out for news radio,
there was two auditions for news radio.
One was a cattle call.
It was like 100 people's giant long
line.
It was like,
and I had a development deal with nbc
and I,
I just didn't know that I was going to
be a part of a cattle calls.
Like this is crazy.
And I went in and the script was not
funny,
like on purpose.
They had decided to write it where they
will weed out all the hams.
They didn't want anybody to read it.
Like,
like what am I supposed to weed out all
that shit.
So I went in,
I read it and I remember talking to my
manager.
He was like,
how'd it go?
Script wasn't funny.
I mean,
I just pretended it was really
happening.
that's all I did.
I just did it like it was really
happening and so then there was only
like a few people that apparently made
the cut and then I went in there for the
second audition.
It was Me and three other dudes who
looked like they were about to fucking
ship off to Vietnam.
They were sweating and they were pale
and you know,
I was 26 at the time so it was only like
four years removed from my last fight or
something like that.
And I looked at all these guys all
nervous and sweaty and I sat on the
couch and I put my feet up and I didn't
even read the script.
I just sat back and I did it like in
front of them.
What's up bitch?
You fucking pussies.
You guys don't know how to perform under
pressure because this is going to be
great mind that I sat there and I like
looked at the script a little bit.
I'm like this.
And it was and it was funny.
That's the way tO do it.
And I had prepared so I knew that it was
funny,
so I was,
I was reaDy.
But when I saw these guys all sweaty is
like,
there's three,
three or four guyS thing.
But they looked like they were just
fucking terrified.
I'll give you one guy was doing it.
He was like,
whoa,
whoa.
He was practicing by himself.
Like that bitch ain't get it.
Looked at.
The other guy looked like he was about
to get shot.
The they look like they're about to die.
And so that alone gave me massive
confidence and I went in there super
loose,
super loose and relaxed.
I'm like,
if it's between me and these pussies,
I got it.
For sure.
Yeah.
And they can sense that constantly to,
well,
yeah,
I did it on purpose
for the guy.
So it's like I was competing against
these guys.
I was like,
I'm going to be,
fuck.
Yeah,
that's what I never get.
I don't get nervous by nature.
I don't get nervous when I have to
perform ever.
And that's the only time because my mind
is telling myself,
it's so ridiculous to be nervous that
I'm literally sabotaging myself where I
was nervous.
It's not ridiculous that you care and
you will not do the wrong thing.
The wrong thing about money.
You're not being in the moment.
You the consequences.
They can't do that.
You're doing it for the wrong reason.
Then if you don't want to act,
I've never been.
You shouldn't be.
There might be like god the money I'm
going to make or if I wouldn't say I've
never once ever in my life thought,
but I think it's because I'm lying.
I'm lying to myself when I go into
vision,
like I can go and I get it.
I go all the way and then I get in there
and now it's just do this.
And I think it's because I'm being a
liar.
I think I'll be,
I don't want to be there,
right?
Because I've never done it.
I didn't want it to.
Well.
So with the exception of one point in
time,
there was doing it at one point in time.
You deeply wanted to be on a sitcom like
you did.
It was all you wanted to do.
You weren't even doing standup for part
thing a lot.
I was doing a lot of plays.
I was doing a lot who are pretending to
be an actor.
It was just like you would talk like one
of them.
You don't that a little bit.
You're relaxed when he's around
executives like it was.
It was talking about a woman,
you know,
like anytime.
Oh,
someone to bring up a woman.
He would immediately be like super
progressive and overemphasize how good
he could.
She is.
she's amazing.
She's amazing and I feel like what she's
like,
good.
We're talking about a female comedian
when you guys were friends from the
jump.
That's what friends are for right off
the bat,
because we never bullshit each other.
I mean we.
There was no like a.
I wasn't pulling the wool over his eyes.
Oh my god.
Well he was on the,
in the worst environment.
The worst environment in my opinion,
is those sketch shows because everybody
is scrambling and being completed.
I did to get and he was the only one
that was cool.
Him and already already was cool as fuck
already lying and it was him and artie
lange.
We're the only ones and me and already
had a scene together and I had a scene
with brian,
but then there was all these other
people that were on the set that were
brutal.
Says mad tv.
Oh my god.
I guess he was our guests.
They weren't mean to me.
No,
everybody was fine with that.
If you look back at those videos,
you get.
I think I sent you the picture.
you guys are so young.
I couldn't believe it was joe since I
was 27.
So funny.
Look at my hair.
It's so beautiful.
I miss it.
I miss it so much at.
That chick was really funny,
man.
What was her name?
That's mary's great.
Mary's shear and who to this day is the
funniest female actor.
probably most talented person I've ever
worked with so far enough back then.
I have a beautiful body.
I'm going to take my shirt off after
this boy.
He had this great character that would
dance around.
Was that a wig you were wearing or was
bleach.
Okay.
that was awake.
High speed.
I got a lot of gay fan mail and a lot of
fan mail deal and I'm not kidding.
You still have the letters I got from
jail.
That woman,
she.
She still weird like leather skin makeup
to make herself look like she was
overtanned and she had this crazy
character.
Jennifer aspinall who is a multimedia
award winning makeup artist and she did
like magical shit.
Joe,
when did you decide acting?
Just acting.
Well,
I really love it.
News radio and I'd love to because it
was just the best case scenario.
Fantastic writing,
great talented actors,
you know,
all of the above was and it never was
successful,
which is perfect because everybody had
to keep trying and nobody ever got a big
head.
It just.
It never made it.
You know,
it barely putt putt putt barely stayed
alive.
It was a perfect environment like with
some really talented people.
Still one of the greatest sitcoms ever.
And you enjoyed the whole process?
Like I didn't enjoy as much as I enjoyed
standup,
but I enjoyed it immensely and way more
than I enjoyed any other things.
After that I saw after that I,
I had development deals for like a year
or two where I.
Which means what?
They give you some money and they try to
put together a sitcom and it's based
around you.
And tHen I got a chance to see what it's
like.
And just actors are like the worst
comedians without punchlines like the
worst comedians,
meaning not like the worst,
like not funny,
but mean the most crazy,
the most neurotic in the,
the actual act itself of auditioning and
trying to get gigs.
It enforces that it.
You're always trying to get people to
love you.
You can always looking for approval,
but you can never just be,
be at peace.
You're always worried that you have to
say the right thing.
You have to be liberal.
If you're not liberal,
if you are a republican,
you better be fucking uber successful
before you come out as worD.
Yeah.
You have to be.
You have to say those things like you
have to be super progressive,
you have to be super left wing and you
also,
you gotta like you gotta like play this
bullshit political game where
everybody's fake.
they're all saying fake things and just
it feels so gross and coming from
comedy,
from the east coast doing standup from
going from fighting and then stand up to
this,
I can't see you for five years.
I get my throat gets tight when we start
talking about because it's all like
nothing Drives me more nuts when guys
pose it,
especially if they're not fighters.
There are fighters.
I get it.
It's the thing,
but when they put their fist up for a
picture,
I told brian,
I go,
fuck is this,
and we bought those guy.
It's a picture of him and his friend
with their fists up.
I go,
why the fuck do people do this?
Why do they.
What is this?
You will never see me put my fist up in.
I never do it.
It's a tool.
It's such.
It's so weird to me.
People have asked me to do it with them.
He put your postdoc for this picture.
I go,
no,
can't do it.
I always want to square off with me and
fucking atlanta.
No,
no.
Come on the face.
but you'll see like big dudes.
I'm not gonna say who the guy is,
but he's a big guy in the pictures on
instagram is like,
look,
I told brian like,
why the fuck you think he does?
I guess because he's not really tough.
It's like an ego thing,
you know,
while there's also like a culture thing,
they think that it's a cool way to
stand.
I don't know.
It's like doing this,
doing the shaka like,
oh,
I take the shot that I'm saying.
It's like that's one of those things
what you're saying,
like other people doing the shaka shaka,
it's like the will ferrell thing and
talladega nights.
I don't know what to do and with whom.
So it's covering his face.
Just first intErview.
Fucking love it.
I love that movie.
Fuck yeah,
Tom cruise.
Use your witchcraft.
I like that they put the v retinas face
tune is running around.
I love how his buddies in his house and
he can't figure out how to work a system
because his buddies banging his wife now
and welfare.
He calls me,
oh,
how do you turn on the radio,
the radio and the tv at the same time,
because I like to party his house and he
fucking cut out his picture and put his
head on the picture.
I've already paralyzed like,
you're not paralyzed in the hospital.
I stab a knife in his fucking
stepbrothers man.
He's so amazing.
Like welfare all.
It's just his ability and nobody.
Nobody has a bad thing to say about him.
Will a great guy,
great guy.
He's a great guy.
Had enough to have friends who played
golf with them.
They were like,
yeah,
he's a competitive guy.
He's not letting you win.
Yeah.
That was such a great moment.
His eyes look at his eyes and the
intensity.
Just girl,
leslie bibb.
That was in that movie.
She's great.
I did zookeeper with her.
She played my girlfriend and then
movies.
You keep her and there's a movie that I
did,
but I only did because Kevin James,
my buddy as well.
I do it.
I didn't have to audition.
Just asked me if you're not,
you're acting but you're not.
You're not like a character.
Yeah.
That's the other one.
Here comes the boom.
I played myself.
That's right.
That was when he was going to be an mma
fighter,
but I only have like a couple scenes and
there's a bunch of kids in mayhem.
Miller.
Yep.
Route and just a paycheck at that point.
Right when I was a buddy of mine asking
me to do something,
but the zookeeper one was fun and I.
It was a kids' movie and I was like,
that'd be cool for my kids to see.
It's cool.
It's silly.
Bunch of monkeys talking to we.
Carol and I have been doing this thing
with firing the kid for fox these
episodes and to me acting is so.
I don't understand.
It's like music actors.
It's so mr.
Athletes or whatever,
man,
I don't give a fuck.
I get how they get their hard work
talent,
but the act in to me is so.
IT's so different.
They're like,
aliens do a good job.
there are.
To me it's just.
It's a weird occupation.
It's very weird and people take it so
god damn seriously and they think it's
so special when people do so well.
You know,
chris rock had a great line that he was
preparing before for.
He's doing the oscars.
He was like,
if you go to see the grammys,
they're singing,
you know the oscars.
they don't even act.
No one does anyThing.
Don't act,
don't do shit.
It's the most boring.
I've hosted it twice.
I don't know what the fuck's going on.
It's true how crunk or people that live
in the category of one,
you probably don't even watch it,
but people are so crunk.
I this guy with $275 million.
One even cares and it's insane.
It's aN award.
It's an award for your make believe
you're really gooD at make belief.
You guys gave to each other.
I just don't do it.
Don't care.
I like movies,
but the award shows to me are so
nonsensical.
Whether it's award shows for comedy or
award shows for music or what.
I don't fucking care.
It doesn't make any sense to me.
Here's the committee.
People like it.
Do they go to see your movie?
Do they enjoy it?
Then you win.
It's like this idea that there's one
better movie than all the other movies
is stupid.
That is weird because it's a human thing
to crown a champion.
Well,
how the fuck did x maki?
Not?
Not when.
I didn't have that.
Not when best movie.
I didn't say it overly reverent.
Yes.
I wasn't a speech impediment.
I was still a really good movie.
Yeah,
it was slow,
but it was amazing.
I never seen the revenant.
Didn't do it for me,
man.
The story wasn't invested in the
character.
I didn't even care so I can't comment.
But the character mokena in the running
for best movie now.
Then your thing is bullshit.
Bullshit is bullshit.
Madmax fucking cleaned up though.
mad madmax.
See thousand movie.
I thought it was pretty good.
It was all right.
It's so fun.
We make pretty unique though.
It was fun not really to remain.
I knew what was gonna happen and using
this for five x market.
I did not know what the fuck was going
to happen and I was wrong at the end,
tell me and I got a sex mock and I was
like,
god damn great movie.
They were nominated for a bunch of
special effects of war.
I think.
Not not this oscar.
I think they won something.
Special effects.
did they did it when I didn't see a
sniff of that movie.
I didn't takE that movie is not allowed
with that.
Did you see it?
Have you seen it?
No,
goddamn man,
goddamn.
He can't get enough of and I highly
doubt anyone here is watching.
WaS the oj simpson thing on ethics keeps
telling me that I suck too.
I was at the store the other night and
they had it in the back comics bar.
They were watching it and Cuba gooding
jr place oj,
which I did not know.
I was like,
dude,
johnnie cochran in that movie when a guy
gives a racist thing,
oscar win as a triumph.
Does it for low budget?
Well it should.
Uhm,
there you go.
It should have one for visual.
It's a goddamn this year.
fantastic.
Moving.
I'll watch it.
It's a fantastic movie.
It's one of my all time favorite movie.
Is it happened in space.
Oh no,
no,
no.
It's about artificial intelligence.
It's about a guY who builds artificial
people.
It's fucking she ai with will smith.
Is tHat what it's called?
IT's not the same.
This robot.
That was good.
It was good.
This is way better.
Really.
It's one of the best movies I've ever
seen in my top 10 all time.
Favorite goddamn rogan.
One hundred percent.
Yeah.
It's right up there with apocalypse
anatomy for real shit.
So it's a great way.
And it's also the implications.
People right now scream.
You're fucking twitter.
You fucking piece of shit.
It's opinions ladies and gentlemen.
That's what you liked.
But um,
the,
there's something about it also to me
because this is a subject that I am
engrossed in,
like almost every next week I read about
artificial intelligence.
Almost everyday I get up,
I'll go to scientific american,
I got all these different websites and I
search.
I will look up artificial intelligence,
go to news,
read tHe latest shit,
and I am is one of the main subjects
that repeats in my mind like a metronome
all day long.
That's your thing,
so that's why you love the movie and
it's going to change.
It's going to change our paradigm.
I think it's going to be the future of
government.
I think I really do.
I think we're going to have rules that
are established by artificial
intelligence and that's gonna.
That's gOnna be how we decide and act
and how we decide and make choices to
see the robots are going to start
running.
Shit.
I really do believe that.
I think that's going to be the solution
to the cult of personality that we're
dealing with right now with Donald Trump
being the front runner for president.
How crazy is that?
I got to tell you right now,
hillary clinton is not going to beat
Donald Trump.
Yes,
she is.
No,
she's not.
I just didn't have a chance.
You're out of your mind.
Is telling you the numbers,
the numbers,
any political pundit and the numbers
just don't add up for trump.
Not true.
They were saying the numbers didn't add
up for him six months ago and they said
he didn't have a chance.
And that sounds like changing are by far
right now unless something changes,
you know,
kind of see this guy to get acting gigs.
No,
either one audition.
Hey brian,
I don't have a dog in the phone.
I like either for you.
Make the statement,
jamie,
look up the numbers.
Hillary clinton's,
uh,
what does it support the approval
approval.
Waiting versus donald.
Let's just look at this and then you
come in before you go.
She's going to win the election.
First of all,
she has huge problems in that.
She's involved in a criminal
investigation.
Might be indicted.
That's,
that's a big issue.
That's the black swan.
The big black swan.
The big fucking issue is that email
thing.
I had Mike Baker on formally cia
operator,
cra opera operative and he was on
yesterday and he was saying anybody
else?
You said it Was me that did the same
thing she did.
I'd be in jail.
Yeah.
He's talking about how they cut and
pasted.
Yeah.
Okay.
Let's see what we got here.
What is,
what Is the red and what is the blue
blue's clinton.
So she's way ahead of them.
Every three to 44,
43 to 46 percent.
what does that graph then?
Why is she above him?
Was that representing time?
Don't understand that graph.
What does that graph mean?
Then?
Percentage of votes.
Pull rep,
pull average.
She's way ahead way ahead and african
americans and latino votes and there's
no way he's gonna cover.
Close that gap.
She's three percent has also got tired
of the democrats.
From what I understand,
women who I think are really down a
tough time of women to who's going to be
with her and who's going to be with him.
I can't believe that was going to be the
running.
Everybody will be with trump except for
not me running mates.
Oh,
running.
Who's going to be his running mate?
Christine?
No fucking way is that fat slob doors to
him.
His fat ass endorsed.
Heres this.
You can't.
You know,
you can't have an addict,
by the way,
that guy's an addict with food.
Yes,
he's an addict.
There's no question about it.
That kind of got a stomach stapled and
he's still fat.
He's crazy.
Fast burst through it or at the
baseball,
he's awesome,
but he's.
He's eating terrible foods.
It's a terrible thing to him,
and I'm not fat shaming,
but I'm saying if you're going to have a
leader,
you cannot have a leader who's by the
way,
hugely anti marijuana.
He said,
marijuana farm,
the president.
We're going to outlaw all this stuff.
You fucking dummy.
You don't even understand what you're.
You're.
You're doing something that's way worse
for your body than marijuana ever will
be critical.
I just don't understand who is going to
be like running with this.
If it's rubio,
he's got a real chance right here.
So participants doing the gops polls
show both clinton and sanders smoking
trump.
It's not going to happen.
Sorry,
donald trump's not going to be the
president and listen that crazy.
It happened so doom the gop.
Bernie sanders be trump,
but that's paul's man.
Pulls are only people willing to answer
polls and they were really bad polls
used to be representative of the winter.
They would go exit polls.
They were so off with with bush versus
kerry.
There were so off that they haven't.
They haven't been actually paul's,
they're just numbers.
I mean,
most of the political pundits who really
are in the know.
When brian went bullshitting,
he does this thing where he calms down
and instead of getting emotional he just
like,
well,
it was more.
I guess he gets like,
I think his dad used to like chastise
him and he would say something stupid.
His dad would know.
My dad would yell,
oh no,
no,
no.
He wouldn't do that.
Now.
My father would do this.
Go ahead and start making it started
making a point.
Watch this,
try this.
Look at this.
Christie faces calls to quit approval.
Drop after backing trump.
I'm wondering why six newspapers calling
for him to resign.
The newspapers were they have people
with opinions.
Why they asking him to resign?
Resign.
What though?
As governor of New Jersey,
why for endorsing trump?
He's just not a good leader.
He's not,
he's not a wise man.
He says things.
who is this?
Trump?
no,
christie trump.
I think trump is more of a showman.
I think christine,
narcissistic entertainer.
Christie says foolish things.
He says,
foolish things that aren't backed by
science.
He's very discriminatory when it comes
to my beloved marijuana.
You can't listen to chris christie when
you're that fat.
I just can't take you serious.
Yeah,
and that's.
You have no discipline.
You don't agree with that.
I know he's no discipline.
When winston churchill who was a
different touch ran and roe,
first of all,
that's english.
The idea that somebody has a weight
problem and they wouldn't be an
effective leader to me is it doesn't
hold water at all.
Really?
Who's the fattest president we've ever
had?
It's not an effective argument.
Well,
first will be prejudicial.
When churchill was from a long time ago
and alcohol was celebrated then as a
manly thing to consume.
If You took the fat,
if you took the fat ratio,
if you took a whatever it is the body
fat test on some of the ceos are great
inventors or scientists or whatever they
were.
I,
I don't know tHat I'm talking about
president president.
I don't have any numbers right now.
There's never been a fact that.
I mean the idea that because somebody is
fat and yes,
he has discipline.
That's just not true.
First of all,
that's not true.
Hold on.
He's not just ridiculous.
He's not fat.
He's a fat guy who's undergone an
operation,
not be fat anymore.
He's still fat.
Saying that you can be.
You can be not discipline in one area or
life,
but have a huge brain and huge intellect
that either,
but he says foolish things and he's fat.
He's a different story.
I'm just saying in general 70,
when you say,
when you generalize and say,
I could not vote for somebody or take
somebody's seriously as a leader because
they're fat for me.
I disagree.
I'm saying for me,
I,
for me,
discriminatory,
yes it is,
but it's also judging someone based on
their own personal choices.
The choices that you make to be an
addict and to not seek out healthy food
and to seek out body harmony.
His body is out of whack.
He's like grossly overweight and he went
through going under like he,
he gave in saying that like I don't have
the discipline to deal with my issue,
so what I'm going to do is go to a
doctor and get cut open so my stomach is
small.
It doesn't matter that there are a lot
of great writers there.
Last thing,
Stephen King,
county major.
Oh,
don't say that.
That doesn't matter.
That's not related.
What do you mean?
THe major alcohol problem that he had
was part of his creative process and
that he was a giant books.
He wrote a book a lot.
I read a book on writing write,
so I read that book to him.
What did he say in the book?
He said,
talked about cell.
He used to drink and do coke and he
would find these fucking.
It was a part of his process.
He realized it was killing him because
he stopped doing it.
ChrisTie is still eating like a pig.
Stephen king makes a very important is
he's an artist.
He's not a leader of the United States
to understand if you don't want to vote
for your leader because he's heavy.
What I'm saying is that the idea that
somebody wouldn't be effective because
they have a weight problem is erroneous.
Doesn't know what I'm saying.
Just tell me the biggest president we've
ever had and go.
Who's the?
Who's the president?
Not a good argument though,
because we don't have a ball president.
Believe it was pretty fast.
Thicker than a snickers right there.
Good.
Especially back charlie.
He's huge,
but was he?
Was he a good president?
Taft was a only input in power for a
very short period back when people were
starving to death,
like when you were a fat.
It was awesome when people were just
money.
Exactly.
Eating and eating and eating and had
been been rich.
It to the fact that we live in a cUlture
now where there's body shaming.
Yeah,
well you're fucked.
You want as your presIdent?
Fuck you.
That's not looking so good.
He's also got this like upper cock fat
that is so it's got like because called.
It's called.
Yeah,
the upper cockfight whiz.
That's a terrible,
and they don't meet with the other
leaders.
They might be right.
This is post surgery.
Yeah.
You have to understand like the
discipline issue,
real discipline.
I hired an agent I.
We were talking on the phone.
He was great on paper.
I met him in person.
I've seen.
He was letting some stuff slip.
I'm like,
oh,
that's weirD.
Me and person.
He's 400 pounds.
I'll let you go,
man.
They're often.
There's some sort of discipline issue.
There has to be day.
You can be in discipline in one side of
your life and very disciplined another.
That is true.
It's compartmentalized and sometimes you
do have an issue and clearly that is a a
food issue,
but I don't want the president United
States struggling with his diet when he
has to make this huge decision.
Going back to this,
the biggest fight in his life and his
health is in danger.
King makes her interesting distinction.
Just somebody brought him up and he
said,
I was a very talented guy with a
substance abuse problem.
That's what he saId.
A lot of people make the mistake of
saying that my substance abuse was the
reason I was so talented.
He said,
nah,
that's not necessarily what he said.
What he said was that the creative
process was enhanced by his substance
abuse problem.
He says,
that's not the case,
but I'm a Stephen King.
Fan is shit that he wrote when he was
fucked up.
That's better.
Way better.
He does better.
He's also an artist.
Big difference,
man.
I want my hardest.
Students wouldn't want Stephen King when
he was coked up balancing my checkbook,
but expanding your mind,
he's got to get in there.
You need to have fucking disciplined.
To be a president,
you need to be a healthy person.
You also need to be a role model.
It's like it's not.
It's a figurehead for the United States
of America.
It's not as simple as just saying Jack
Kennedy was a huge womanizer.
Consider no,
that's a different thing,
man.
It's a different thing.
First of all,
and we didn't know.
No one knew back the slop what's right
in front of his face.
It's a different world.
Back then the world was different,
but it was a breakdown in,
in self control,
right?
In one way or an ab or it was just
standard operational procedure.
Don'T become a leader by just dating one
chip.
That's what I'm saying.
Is dick
slingers presidential fixing it might be
food though,
is all I'm saying.
Well,
it's a different thing though because it
wasn't enough.
It wasn't interfering with his health.
Like chris christie,
his physical body is 10 years massively,
massively falling apart and the guy got
a fucking operation and it didn't do
much.
Me still grossly overweight.
I mean he used to be way bigger.
It doesn't bother you at all.
Killing must want my president of
superhero kind of being a contrarian
here.
I really do.
I actually don't know if it bothers me
or not what I was.
Let me tell you.
No,
I.
I understand that explore and I think
that's a good point.
Where sport would it?
Does it bother you?
You said you don't know if it bothers
you.
Just health.
Health is important for presence,
like they have to go through all those
health checks.
That's why trump came out and they said,
fuck.
They said,
I'm in great shape.
What's up?
I read obama shit.
I think that I think that I'm not trying
to be a contrarian at all.
I understand and respect somebody's
point of view where they say,
you know what,
you are not able to control your own
biology.
Therefore I wonder what your judgment
would be like as a leader.
One hundred percent valid.
WhaT you're judging a person when
they're running for president.
You 100 percent judge.
Sure,
and we do judge massively short in the
department of taking care of his own
physical being.
Most of us,
and we know that most of us when we hire
somebody,
if one guys in shape,
the other guy's not,
we're gonna just instinctly go.
We're going to make those conclusions.
And that in a way is fair in terms of
how you look at the world where you say,
you know what,
if you can't draw your own biology,
I wonder what else you can't control.
And as a fat person,
you know,
you're walking into that or at least
have to take responsibility for whatever
the world by this.
It's so hard thing.
I just don't buy it.
I just fucking lost 10 pounds.
I didn't even.
Wasn't even fat.
It's different.
It's not different.
Why is it challenging?
Even if he's otherwise did still make
decisions for me than it is for him.
I'll tell you how I think some people,
for example,
have a predilection not only to put on
weight because their endocrine system is
just whacked,
but also some people do have addictions
and addictions are very powerful and
he's an addict.
And some people,
I don't want to say this,
my president,
whether it's drugs,
alcohol.
That's what I'm saying is that what I'm
saying is that to just.
We live in a culture now that just puts
so much emphasis on the physical and I
think there are a lot of people who have
been overweight and who have eaten too
much or had a thing for sugar who still
are incredibly,
incredibly beneficial and to society.
And they would finish things and done
things that you know that.
And they were just.
They were huge.
They were huge intellects.
Yeah.
Well that's a different story.
But they were huge intellects.
That was a lot of smart people that are
fat for sure.
But that's.
You don't want them running the big
show.
There's a difference between someone
who's a really smart fat person who's a
great singer or smart fat person who's
really good at telling jokes.
There's a big difference between that
and a fucking president.
A president is not just
a guy who can talk to this guy and make
good decisions.
He's a fucking figurehead for the United
States of America.
The greatest super power the world has
ever known.
For us to say,
chris christie's,
the best we could do is a disgrace to
different subjects like you.
You have all your bases.
You have to cover all your bases.
It's exactly the subject.
What's that?
You're talking specifically about chris
christie.
I'm talking about somebody talked about.
Yeah,
we talked about chris christie.
Who stomach got.
I reacted.
I reacted to.
I don't know if I could.
I don't want to vote for somebody who
looks like that.
Yeah.
Him and for me,
it wouldn't make as much.
He's the only one.
You're.
You're arguing semantics now because
that's the one guy looks like that.
He's the only guy.
Maybe trump's not skinny.
He's a fat fuck too.
If you saw trump,
but I was close on.
You throw up.
Exactly.
Trump.
Trump killed him.
Those fucking welcome to my nightmare.
All those guys together.
Look,
I,
I'm,
I'm sure there's rubio flexing on them.
Fools.
First of all,
who are those other people?
Where you guys?
Ted cruz and chris christie.
Marco rubio ran parson ben carson.
Who's that other guy?
Dennis Dennis Case,
which I think that stands.
He's the governor.
Governor had done a good job.
Yeah.
Then you have a jelly shows.
He's alive.
You have priority voting for that guy.
Jeb bush is always put on way too.
He's got it.
He's always been a problem.
How is this guy still in there that
keisha shish guy was.
He was a pretty effective as Ohio
governor.
Photos come out of all those guys like a
orgy.
So weird.
Like finally I'm what's left again.
I'm all I'm thinking about.
Is the mma fan going?
What the fuck man.
Fucking breakdown by chris christie.
We didn't promise it would've said we
warned you.
We.
We talked about conor for an hour.
No,
10 minutes.
Connor.
We broke some of.
And wHat do you think about who's going
to win?
Thank you.
Janet had just put the fucking.
let's go.
Yeah,
I fucking hate this.
Chris christie talk makes me angry.
Fucking horrible politics.
She's was watching you guys the fucking
thing,
man.
That's my state where I was born and
that.
That reminds you,
reminds you of a lot of shit that he did
with the bridge.
The shutting down that bridge to
political decision to make.
To do that.
It's so far.
It's criminal.
Shut down a bridge to try to.
I don't want to talk about it.
Get angry.
Get fucking fights.
So we know the size difference we were
to their heights.
I guess it doesn't really matter.
Think taller.
Yeah.
Three inches taller and he has a two
inch reach advantage says to.
Yeah.
Hmm.
That's interesting.
That's going to play a big factor
because obviously,
and moves in so much isn't used to
fighting bigger guy,
but now he is.
But the thing is,
if you've seen pictures of the video is
he's fucking huge right now.
The leg reach thing,
he's,
he's got longer legs to.
yeah,
there you go.
Exactly.
He uses them real well and really well
at distance.
It's not like me where I just want to
step in and club your legs.
He's trying to try to try to negate that
gap between him and he likes to throw a
lot of front kicks to the body like you
did with Chad and the against the ideas.
Let me ask you this on creepy.
How about uh,
uh,
w with connor,
he's always been the bully,
right?
He's kind of bullied the 1:45
division and then now here there's no
way,
you know,
he's just not bigger than dia's.
So I think it's the first time we're
really going to see him where his size
and can be that advantage anymore.
But he's pretty goddamn big right now.
He wAs training for fighting at 1:55,
which means he ate like a pig,
fought at 1:55
and in the uk.
So he's fought at 1:55
before and starch guys with one shot.
I absoluTely believe it's power carries
over 200 percent to 1:55.
and this fight is essentially at one 70,
but it's,
these are one $55 that don't have to cut
weight.
That's what's going on.
They don't have to cut weight because it
was part of the agreement.
When nate took the fight,
they took it at a catch weight.
Well,
you know,
deals was down to go to I think one,
six x five slash 16 congress.
No,
no man,
I want you to.
I want you to have the advantage here
and the weight.
What?
We're going to make it one 70.
Don't kill yourself.
Don't want to cut weight.
Look.
And you shouldn't.
I think.
Listen,
I think this is the future and I really
truly hope that people decide to fight
at a much more reasonable weight class.
I think they decided to do this where
they fight,
where they actually belong and stopped
this dehydration process.
Man,
it's fucking madness.
It's the worst aspect of mma.
The most dangerous aspect of mma.
The scariest now because there's no ivy
rehydration,
so these people are going in there with
dehydrated brains and it taken shots.
The fucking dome.
I think it's stupid.
It ruins Your chin.
It ruins your ability to fight at the
best level and lung.
Longevity,
longevity also.
Yeah.
The a huge x factor too Is nate diaz.
They go,
well,
he's getting ready for a trIathlon.
I don't give a fuck.
That's not five rounds of fighting the
ufc.
I don't care what you're doing.
There's no way you can make up for that.
Well,
I don't know because I don't know what
else he was doing other than training
for the triathlon.
I don't know if he's doing jujitsu.
I don't know if he was boxing.
I know he's definitely training for a
triathlon though,
which means it's not like you caught him
sitting on the couch doing bong hits and
eating cheetos.
True guys in really good shape,
different shape.
it is a different shape,
but there's also no wear and tear from a
fight camp and that can be a big factor
in his favor.
well,
diaz did say he goes,
you know,
to me there's no pressure.
I mean,
he goes,
I've had,
I've had cancer,
I've had full camps.
I went in there and got my ass whooped.
You and I've had times where I was
sitting on the couch for three weeks,
went into the gym,
beat everybody up.
He's like,
so for me it's,
you know,
it's just another day.
I think a big factor,
a really big factor is the fact that he
doesn't have to cut weight.
I think it's a big factor for connor to.
I mean when we might see the best condom
we've ever seen because seeing him at
145 pounds,
that guy was on death's door the day
before the fight,
the Chad mendez fight.
He looked like uttered dog shit at the
weigh ins and then the next day he's
full and thick and probably 20 plus
pounds heavier than he was at the wayne.
I'll tell you what gets scary is if diaz
does get mcgregor down.
Oh yeah.
Mcgregor.
It's very scary.
Oh,
you're talking about a high level
jujitsu with lots of submissions and tse
has got some serious fucking skills from
top and bottom to.
Yeah.
Really,
really good.
You just too.
But see george lockhart has been working
with george or if conner for the last
fighter too,
so you know that he's not just eating a
bunch of shit.
Right?
He's putting mean on a cellular level.
He's,
he's energizing his body With really,
really good high high energy fuel stuff.
So him putting on that much weight,
which is just more natural form.
He's going to be fucking so strong,
so strong.
Such good cars.
So healthy.
You know,
if he gets by this,
I think you have to do ufc 200 if dos
anjos is ready.
Yeah.
If we can inspire them.
But with that said,
if would have nate diaz lights them up.
My,
I don't see that happening.
Then we don't have to deal with this
shit anymore.
Well we do.
You want to deal with this shit though?
We trust the sport needs that man.
I don't want.
I don't want the connor shorter ads like
I want it to keep going.
I really.
It's magical.
It's magical because he is got the guts
to talk so big and then just to go up to
78 and he's just.
Yeah,
but I don't think nate diaz,
if he beats him,
I don't think he ends the connor train.
I think he stops it momentarily.
There's a regrouping and he comes back
better than ever.
I just don't.
I don't think losing to nate diaz stops
everything.
I think it definitely hits a bump in the
road,
man.
No more of that.
Undefeated or anymore.
We'll look at what happened to manny
pacquiao.
I fought one male,
one male marquez and got knocked dead.
Look,
I planted the same.
Not the same,
but he came back and it's still just as
huge as he's ever been mad.
It's not the same as floyd though.
Like floyd was huge.
right?
Never lost.
Even though it's fights were born.
We still tuned in.
He's still the best of all time.
He had like this huge undefeated or
about him.
He loses with his fighting style.
Get the fuck out.
Well,
if he loses,
he's boring to watch undefeated,
so that's tuned in.
He also refused to find some guys in
their prime like manny pacquiao five
years ago,
six years ago,
but stand up.
Stop right there because he had a real
good argument that manny pacquiao was
most likely on performance.
Enhance,
refused to take the drug test.
So there's a reason why it moved up.
Eight weight classes kept his knockout
power.
Look,
I don't know whether or not many it did
anything,
but that alex a risa guy that was with
him,
that guy torso notoriously known for it.
That was a strength and conditioning
coach and the reputation is usually.
It's usually pretty active.
Jose conseco in my corner and then be
like,
I don't know man.
One hundred and 98 pounds.
It's weird.
You went up eight waist classes and jose
conseco says fucking best friend.
I think he's good man.
Strength and conditioning coach.
A lot of guys get purple like that.
What happens?
I guess it's like blood rushing to your
skin or something.
They get a sweat on flexing and they
just.
Yeah.
Well also I think when you take a lot of
testosterone like that,
from what I understand,
like you developed,
you have more blood,
you have more blood in your system.
Yeah.
Like this dude I knew who was on like
heavy dose of testosterone.
His doctor,
he was going to.
He's doing some endurance thing and his
doctor told him,
you should give blood.
You should take some blood out of your
body.
Before he was going to do some crazy
bike ride,
like you should get rid out of your
body,
your blood do thick.
There's a theory that says that the
reason women don't die of heart
problems,
they don't have the kind of cholesterol
issues is because they bleed once a
month and and this guy said if you give
blood once a year,
it might be the best thing you can do
for your heart.
Your body.
Yeah.
Why?
Because apparently it keeps your blood
thInner and so as a result you will.
And I'm,
by the way,
I'm not a doctor,
I'm paraphrasing this guy,
so please don't kill me.
Play exactly.
But essentially he said you can lower
your lipid levels and all this other
stuff by giving blood once a year and it
makes a huge difference.
Uh,
it's a,
it's a school of thought.
It's been,
it's been disputed,
like a pint,
I guess.
Been disputed.
whoa.
What,
what was,
what's supposed to be the benefit?
How's it lower your blood?
So I guess apparently you,
like you said,
you get thick,
you know,
your blood gets thick,
you get an and,
and it kind of acts as I suppose like
aspirin would where you are,
your blood gets into your body to
rejuvenate and more blood than.
It was interesting that women don't get
the kind of heart attacks that men do.
I always attributed that to stress.
Well,
no,
it's estrogen.
I thought estrogen and it's also
according to this coUple oF these
doCtors that they,
they bleed once a month and that hasn't,
that has an effect because they're evil
creatures.
Excuse me,
sir.
Excuse me.
They give heart attacks.
Don't get them.
That's true.
But I cut myself in,
suck on it.
Like I thought,
you know,
I kinda like,
oh shit and that.
No,
we didn't cut yourself on purpose.
Fall down and scrape myself and suck
because I thought it would go back into
my bottle.
Give wrong stupid.
Kinda does kind of just doesn't go back
into your blood.
THe nutrients go in your body.
You would think I want to go do a full
like screening of vitamins,
hormones,
everything I've ever done that.
Have you done cryotherapy yet?
Let's go do it right now.
Dude.
I got into a really cold pool.
Almost panicked.
Those aren't the same.
My asshole heart both were like,
that's not like an ice bath.
It's not.
To me it's the ice baths.
Stronger,
stronger for,
for me,
an ice bath is more effective.
Well that's what I'm iceman hof.
Wim hoff.
He said like for your,
like your soul,
like your,
your
resiliency and being able to overcome a
nice bath is better.
It's way longer because it's just your,
you know,
your porn bags of fucking ice in tHat
water and you get in there and you're
brutalized for saudi minutes.
Some people swear by cryo therapy.
I did it.
My last camp I did it four times a week
and I didn't see much of a difference as
opposed to ice baths,
so I stopped doing with ice bath.
Maybe it's a.
I'm like what you felt versus the actual
anti inflammation markers in your blood
because they've definitely shown that
there's a there.
It reduces inflammation.
pretty radically better.
Better than an ice bath,
but better because I don't.
I don't know.
I don't know how much.
How much has been shown that a ice bath
do?
I don't know.
I'm more aware of what they've shown
from a cryotherapy,
but where it's really effective.
It's for people with arthritis.
This is lady that goes to the place that
I go to and this poor lady,
her hands are jacked man.
like her whole life or has it been like
this?
Just like snarled up clause and she now
for the first time in a decade can
straighten her fingers out and she never
thought about just filling up buckets of
ice and put.
It seems like you should write maybe.
I don't know what she's done before.
I should've asked her.
Well,
it's,
it's like my daughter.
I'm actually partnering up with the
cryoablation in lake forest or balls
deep opening up march,
March 15th.
We opened up March 15th called therapy
kraus along lake forest.
Um,
my daughter has juvenile rheumatoid
arthritis.
I take her in my craft machine or my,
the lady I used to go to monica newport,
our custom mesa.
Well,
it sparked my interest and then I
realized that it fucking works.
You know,
the science is behind it.
I'm talking about how deeply penetrates.
I heard it penetrates deeper than a ice
bath,
but I've done ice baths my whole life.
they're fucking way different.
TheY hurt my toes and feet.
So I'm always like trying to stick them
into the pain to.
Do they Sit in an ice bath typically 15,
15 minutes?
Yeah,
I do.
In both the,
there's a,
there's a korean bath asked by my gym
right next,
right next to it.
So d and I,
and I don't know this nice bath.
So the korean bath house.
Oh yeah.
I your sweet.
Am I supposed to be sweet?
I'm a little.
My bedding don't know.
aggressive,
you've never seen a small deal,
you've ever seen a small thing until
you've gone to a korean bath houses.
oh,
will you try and say,
is that racist?
No,
it's science.
Does it smell like kimchi?
You know,
all kinds of things.
All kinds of dicks at these places.
ramen noodles is like japanese isn't the
wrong race yesterday,
man.
It's fucking tiny.
But before you put your daughter in the
cryotherapy chamber,
did you ever just have her take ice bath
and did it help?
Uh,
we put ice on her before,
but she was two and a half when she got
diagnosed.
She didn't like ice,
but then we're also getting things like
the hyperbaric chambers.
So kNow with her ailment or disease,
you know,
if she hasn't had a flare up in a long
time,
it's because we feed her the right food.
She's gluten free.
Sugar free.
The hyperbaric
chamber help where I haven't put it on
one yet.
I haven't,
I haven't gotten one yet,
but I'm getting the adjuStments that
you've made in the diet.
They've had a pretty big impact.
Having a low inflammatory food diet is
has first.
So she was running by 10 months,
I mean she was,
she's ahead of the curve,
really smart.
Then to see her not being able to walk
or a little kid having brain fog that
comes with,
with ra and I mean I,
I,
I was a mess,
you know,
and she can agenda but skew it.
And then finally we started to do all
the,
all the food,
the food has changed and now she's w we
fixed her quickly,
we got on it right away and she's okay
now she's good days.
And you wouldn't notice it or you would
have no idea.
I mean there'S no more.
She was limping a bit with sad,
funny I guess whatever she got diagnosed
when I tore my hip.
So we're botH limping around the house
and limping around disneyland and
limping around everywhere.
But I think it maybe kind of made her
feel better.
So what,
what did,
what did you dairy free,
gluten free,
processed sugar,
free processed sugar free.
And how long did it take before he saw
an impact?
Not long.
It took maybe a montH or two and then
after six months fast.
I mean six months.
It was huge.
After a year it was gigantic.
Now what else you do?
What?
Do you give her?
Any supplements,
fish oil or anything along those lines?
Yeah,
I mean we mix in things like,
you know,
a mct oil or all this health stuff.
My family is very healthy.
My dad is.
My dad is the one that has kept this
diet from falling apart.
Realistically.
I call them enough food nazi,
but he's,
you know,
it's me and him raising my daughter
together.
Actually my mom just moved into my
house.
My parents had been together for 15
years,
but they're together now.
Now.
Now they live together and I lived there
and I'm like,
oh cool.
I live with my parents and my kid
after.
No,
I love that.
It's a cluster fuck.
but I love him for it and then I,
you know,
that's awesome.
So they're doing that to help you?
Yeah.
That's cool.
That's beautiful.
And my mom
as a chef,
my dad's a very healthy guy,
so the food in my house is all geared
around my daughter.
IF I want to cheat on my diet,
I have to leave my house,
I have to feel bad and I have to just
sit in my car and cry.
We're going to go through some gummy
bears.
That's great man.
It's great that you could find something
that quick that can make that big of an
impact and like I said,
this,
this diet that I'm on,
it makes me really considered the impact
that food has on your body and this is
one of the reasons why I'm so harsh on
that chris christie guys,
because I don't want anybody that's a
representative of the unIted states or
us or a leader that shows the populist,
which shows this,
this willingness to give it.
I want that to them to be exceptional.
If you want to be super girl,
exactly superhero.
That's having some discipline and
understanding that there's some severe
consequences to not having that
discipline and when you're a massively
overweight guy like that.
The amount of aches and pains.
Our whole motto.
Yeah.
So when kids look up to and they see
this fat ass being the leader and like,
well,
you know,
it's just amazing that a young girl who
developed this horrible ailment can get
relieF so quickly just by adjusting your
food.
It makes me never want to eat that shit
again.
It really does.
It makes me want to cut all that stuff
out of my life forever.
I think I mArried,
if americans learned how to eat,
we wouldn't have like one of the biggest
issues is always like healthcare and
stuff like that.
I wonder how many ailments would not be
a factor if people ate better.
Well,
you know,
I watched this documentary with my kids
on corn syrup are on syrup and sugar.
It was,
I forget,
it's called,
I think it's called that sugar
documentary and we went through the
supermarket and you start grabbing
things and looking at how much sugar is
in everything subsidized for everything.
Everything.
It's in everything
and it's,
it's so deeply ingrained in everything.
We do,
everything we eat,
sugar,
sugar.
It's know fed up.
That other document you're talking about
that they point out so many good points.
That sounded weird,
but
it all makes sense.
You can.
You can turn around anything and there's
fucking sugar in it and everything is so
manipulative time.
You guys had fast food.
Well,
I haven't had anything anywhere near it
in a month,
so I started this diet.
I was trying to figure out when I
started I had to go back and look at the
clock or the calendar rather february.
First was the first day that I started
the diet.
Did you have fast food before that knit?
Well,
yeah.
I'm sure I did.
I edit katz deli when I was in New York
and I decided after I ate that that was
going to be the last.
This is going to be my last blow out
meals.
I had to pastrami sandwiches at a reuben
and a corned beef sandwich was
delicious.
You don't miss the.
Nope.
I'm good for one or two.
I could eat it,
but I don't want to know man.
The benefits are for a little bit of
mouth.
Pleasure.
Here's the thing,
dude.
You know what?
I really like,
I like steak come in fat,
fucking juicy elk stake that.
I cook on the grill.
I like greens,
la,
grow healthy food.
That's what I like when I sit down and I
eat like a nice elk steak with some
fucking kael feel good,
feel great.
That's what I like.
That's what I crave.
I enjoy that.
That's my favorite kind of meal.
How long did it get you to take out
carbs for you?
Felt like that dude.
I'll tell you what,
man.
I got a headache the first couple of
days.
That was weird.
Um,
where my body was like,
I hate to use the word detoxing.
Withdrawals going through detoxing man.
He talks to me,
but that's what was going on.
It was sugar,
sugar.
The sugar I think was the headache thing
because I'd cut out sugar before and I
got a headache.
I think that's what it is.
And then you drink on this at all?
They can have a little,
but I haven't been.
You were tried cutting out caffeine.
Coffee?
yeah,
I tried to slas.
SHivering.
I love when I write,
when I write,
like really sit down.
I'm trying to finish something.
I drink wAy too much.
Graphene and I took some time off after
last time I did,
it was a long time ago and last time I
went on like a real binge where I was
just drinking coffee all day everyday
for like a month.
That Would be today and then I went like
just one or two days off in my head was
killing me.
Just like,
oh,
it was in a vice.
That was worse.
Mom,
it was probably like right up there with
the sugar thing.
The sugar thing was like for three days,
two or three days I was fogged.
Sugar would be a big hurt,
no one.
Here's another big hurdle when you
convert from your body,
eating mostly carbs and using that for
fuel to trying to go into ketosis and
burn fat for fuel.
You feel like a bitch like your week?
Like when I go to the gym,
when I'm lifting weights,
I'm trying to push like,
oh,
you still feel that way or he didn't
know gone.
It's gone.
I worked out today.
I felt great,
but the push part,
the beginning,
like it's hard to get through things so
I can decision,
but you have to have discipline.
This is what you gotta do,
man.
You got to write.
I didn't write this down because I mean
I knew I wasn't going to cheat.
I just like,
this is how.
This is what I'm going to do this I'm
doing and so I did it,
but if you don't,
if you don't have that mindset or you're
not used to doing that kind of thing,
just write it down.
Write down what you're going to do
today.
Today,
I'm not going to eat sugar.
I'm not going to eat carbs.
I'm not gonna.
Eat that and write that down every
goddamn day and then check it off at the
end of the day.
That way you know you did it.
If you just leave it to like the ether,
just put it out there and just,
you know,
indian,
y'all wishy washy with it.
You're not going to be disciplined.
You just know it's so.
It's not an option.
So like I told you,
I had that dream and I was eating bread
was dreaming.
I was like,
but it was only cornbread.
I had a dream that doesn't like
cornbread.
I had a dream.
I was different kinds of bread and
butter was another one was like a,
like a cheesy roles.
You get it like fogo de chao,
those,
the warm cheesy rules this gets.
I'm having a fucking red lobster,
red lobster,
but it'll just hanging out in Brazil,
walking around and grabbing those little
bags of cheese balls.
I never been to Brazil.
Oh,
you gotta go man.
That's great.
I give myself 10 years.
I'll look like chris christie.
You're fine.
But it's just.
I don't know.
That fat is way,
way,
way lighter than it used to be because
you can't get your stomach stapled
unless you're like fucking.
Well there was one picture where he's
just morbidly obese.
That was before.
That was after his surgery.
I want that as my friend president where
he's wearing those pants.
Yeah.
I have a lot of fat friends.
I mean,
they're awesome.
Yeah.
Look,
I've morbidly obese friends.
It's not the.
That's not the issue.
No,
I don't have an issue with all that.
They're fun,
man.
I wish I was more like them.
It's just like there's a.
There's a position that is the most
highly valued position in the world.
That's the president of the United
States.
You got to be an x man.
You got to be a bad motherfucker.
You demand a lot from your president
doesn't.
There's no one like that
is running right now.
There's no one.
There's no one fits that bill and that's
why it's so sweet.
Fit that bill knows damn well they don't
want to be president to smart.
Well also the fact that you get so you
get everything about your past gets
raked over with a fine tooth comb.
We way over three hours right now are.
We were way over.
Alright kids.
Let's.
Thanks chris.
Christie,
let's wrap this up.
Up.
There he is.
Look at that.
You know,
post surgery.
By the way.
I thought it was just a big husky guy.
Come on bro.
He deflated this for upper smart guy.
no,
that's not even a manly gut.
Like a manly gut is like joey diaz to
ideas as a manly cut.
Can see he.
Can he see his cock you or is it too
pushed into the seat of.
He has a mere strange,
uh,
insane look,
right?
He looks comfortable.
It looks comfortable.
Lounge chair.
Like somebody just put a bunch of car.
Does she looks comfortable.
Warren cheese.
The sec.
Ladies and gentlemen,
the end.
I love the fuck out of you guys.
So much fun to do.
March 16th,
irvine,
improv brown,
killing myself.
I will be there.
I will be there with my beautiful
girlfriend.
Tickets on us.
My man denver,
um,
Ice house tonight.
I think there's like 10 tickets.
Still left.
A greg fitzsimmons,
jenny johnson,
tony hinchcliffe and fuck else is on the
show.
Someone else?
Duncan trussell.
That's right.
God dammit.
That's it.
You fucks.
And then a friday night,
I'm at the car theater at the mgm with
joey diaz and tony hands cliff in vegas.
Hala.
That's it folks.
Thank you so much.
See you soon.
Bye.
See you tomorrow with bert kreischer and
bright red bands.
See ya.